what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so what I want to do here is begin
getting into what I consider to be one
of the best stories ever written in
Marvel Comics Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four but because this story is
so expansive and there's other things
that I want to cover this series will
actually serve as a backdrop and that in
addition to my other videos this series
will be uploaded as well allowing for
two a days until we finish so instead of
going through and providing a large
narrative on why the story was written
instead what I want to do here is
provide this information as we progress
through the series itself and the reason
why is that for Hickman's Fantastic Four
the series actually draws this emphasis
from the entire history of the team with
special emphasis placed on Civil War
what I mean here is that with this story
having started in 2009 and Civil War
having it written in 2006 prior to Civil
War reads role within the Marvel
Universe was largely that of an explorer
and chronicler of Science and Technology
however during the events of Civil War
and because the conflict was a symptom
of a larger problem involving the
warring nature of humanity Reed Richards
set about to quite literally solve the
problem of everything opening up with
Reed Richards and his father Nathanael
this particular bit of the story is
something I'd like you to keep in the
back of your head since the concept of
father and son will be a recurring theme
throughout this series especially
because a story itself largely
emphasizes Franklin Richards but this
moment comes to us as a flashback to
Reed's childhood while we will learn
more about the relationship between the
two within the will of Marvel comics
Nathaniel Richards first appeared in
Fantastic Four number 272 as the father
of Reed albeit in an absentee form
however with these original appearances
from John Byrne almost no information
was offered about Nathaniel saved the
fact that he abandoned Reed Richards and
his mother three years before the
Fantastic Four gained their powers what
this expansion of Hickman does is
established that the moral compass of
Reed in terms of his willingness to fail
for the sake of discovering tales from
the lessons handed down to him by his
father who plays a significant part in
his life despite having been gone for so
long but following this flashback we
jump to the present day with the
Fantastic Four facing off against a
villain known as the wizard now in truth
this battle is not really designed to
play any major or significant
instead this is simply designed to show
us what the Fantastic Four are doing in
the current day and that this error of
their lives has them fighting his
superheroes and so with the wizard
defeated almost immediately after
sifting through the robots of the wizard
the Fantastic Four come to the
realization that the wizard himself has
been building robots designed to work as
proxies carrying out his will through
destruction
now while this seems like the normal
actions of a villain after accessing one
of the robots self-destruct mechanisms
and tracing the signal back to its
source Reed arrives at the Wizards lair
only to discover that he's been
systematically developing a race of
robotic humans and children while we
don't know exactly what the purpose
behind this is Pikmin provides us with
an explanation when the story shifts its
focus to the aftermath in the Baxter
building where Johnny Storm and Ben
Grimm go back through normal actions of
jiving one another during a conversation
with Sue Reed's mind jumps back to the
wizard who argued off panel that
humanity would inevitably destroy itself
now again this ties directly into civil
war and now with Tony Stark operating as
a director of shield and the fifty state
initiative in place which is to say a
government-sanctioned superhero team in
all 50 states because civil wars but the
superhero community down the middle with
the remainder of Steve Rogers Avengers
operating underground the Wizards claim
of society's imminent destruction rings
in the mind of Reed who's put his brain
to task and appears to have come to the
same conclusion and so taking to a room
within the Baxter building which is
off-limits to everyone else we
discovered that in addition to a litany
of ideas in the mind of Reed his top
goal at the moment appears to be his
desire to solve the problem of
everything now this bit is extremely
important because what Hickman's gonna
do is effectively turn the entirety of
the Fantastic Four concept on its head
stepping into a multi-dimensional bridge
something that I hope you notice is that
if you see my videos on time runs out
this looks almost identical to the
device used by Reed to view the
multiverse in an attempt to decipher why
the multiverse was collapsing prior to
Secret Wars it's for this reason that if
you choose to the writings of Jonathan
Hickman within marvel comics can
actually be read in isolation and in
chronological order revealing a complete
story unto itself dealing with multiple
facets of a superhuman community that
said after initially speaking to a
disembodied voice we learn that
these men are actually different
versions of read from different
realities what we're told is that Reed
Richards of Earth six five nine zero and
Reed Richards of Earth twelve hail from
realities were the Fantastic Four were
exposed to the cosmic radiation they
granted their powers but instead of
developing the power to stretch their
bodies one gained the abilities of
Johnny Storm and the other gained the
abilities of Susan storm
now while Hickman will touch lightly on
the face of the other Fantastic Four
members from each of these continuities
for the moment Reed's taken before the
Council of Reed's within a hall that
exists outside of all space and time as
a result the council is able to perform
their work within the hall without
having to worry about negatively
impacting the multiverse around them in
addition to this after entering the hall
proper we learned that the council
consists of a litany of reads from
different realities and with different
powers as an example and one reality
Reed Richards is a mutant that leads the
x-men but in another reality he became
the Silver Surfer or Doctor Strange
however before being able to receive a
proper tour and after the council is
alerted to an invasion of Earth by
Galactus and the 2:01 to reality Reed is
greeted by three versions of himself
with each one wielding an Infinity
Gauntlet and so with Fantastic Four
number 571 the comic picks up were 570
left off with the council preparing to
do battle against Galactus of Earth to
zero one two now on its face where this
seems to be a massive conflict that
seven of the reads have a symbol to face
off against Galactus and three silver
surfers we actually learned that each of
these reads is wielding an ultimate
nullifier then a sidetrack for a second
if you recall my comic concepts video on
the ultimate nullifier itself we had
talked about how the device serves to
completely extinguish and eliminate
anything in existence up to and
including the universe while I wouldn't
say that this is a Glary plot hole
Marvel had previously established that
there was no limit to what the ultimate
nullifier could destroy within any given
universe meaning that a person with the
intelligence and willpower of Reed
Richards only really needs one
however with there being seven
nullifiers here the indication is that
perhaps this version of Galactus is too
powerful to be destroyed by a single
nullifier but it's entirely possible
that Hickman missed this piece of
information but regardless of the reason
for this following the off panel
destruction of Galactus we switched to
earth eight nine zero one as Reed is
being educated
about the council's purpose what we're
told is that the read from earth 8901
initially put his mind to task of
solving the universe's issue of hunger
by terraforming a section of a barren
and uninhabitable planet while we're not
told how this was initially done but we
are told is that over time this 25
square mile hatch agree to cover the
entire planet and extended to other
worlds within this universe as a result
the read of Earth 8901 turned his sights
to feeding the hungry throughout the
multiverse by using the food from these
planets to send supplies through an
interdimensional portal to other
realities in addition to this while Reed
Richards from the earth eight nine zero
one reality does possess an Infinity
Gauntlet the gamma only works in the
reality that it heals from now this bit
of information is extremely important
and the reason why as a prior to this
revelation the only information on the
limits of the gauntlet came during the
2003 crossover JLA and Avengers when
Darkseid picked up the gauntlet but
couldn't use it however with this
statement had been effectively wrote the
limit of the gauntlet in stone making it
in continuity which has remained an
aspect of his existence
ever since now for here we jumped to the
earth 45 reality on day 3 of reach
education and pick up with the darker
side of the council what we learned here
is that because the council exists to
solve the problem of everything not
every solution is peaceful or honorable
instead the council must occasionally
delve into the realm of the unthinkable
in order to keep the multiverse safe in
this instance because every story that
involves Doctor Doom sees him attempting
to gain absolute power for the goal of
ruling that reality the council had
taken it upon themselves to capture each
iteration of dr. doom which would aspire
to evil as a result and within the tomb
below the main council chamber are
countless versions of doom who have had
inhibitor collars placed around their
necks which destroys higher brain
functions and turns each version of doom
into a vegetable now on its face this
seems like an outrageous situation and a
complete paradox to the role of the
council and serving as a guiding force
for the universe but in truth I actually
agree with it decide check for a second
when I was younger I read a book called
injustice what's the right thing to do
by Michael Sandel and in it he provided
a scenario of a trolley train in this
situation you're the conductor of a
trolley when the brakes go out and the
only recourse you have is to adjust the
tracks if you stay on course
you'll kill five construction workers
but if you adjust course you'll kill
only one this situation falls directly
in line with the utilitarian philosophy
of doing the greatest good for the
greatest number of people however the
other side of this equation is the
line-drawing if everyone who
demonstrates incorrigible evil is
stripped of their freedom and the goal
of the council is to solve the problem
of everything then stripping everyone of
their freedom is the only logical
conclusion to eliminating war and
conflict
now while this does fire allowed into a
ton of new arguments I'm actually
curious as to whether or not you all
agree with the idea of the council
stripping Doom of his freedom and his
mind but following this situation we
transition to another flashback of Reed
having a conversation with his father
discussing his troubles at school and
said on the issue being that Reed is
constantly picked on and the problem
that he faces is that no one in school
is able to keep up with him on an
intellectual level and that because of
his intelligence Reed feels like an
outcast offering words of comfort
Nathanael states that the intelligence
Reed possesses is a struggle at his
young age because he's not in position
to use it properly but when the time
comes to truly help the world
rediff will be able to expand beyond his
own sphere of influence and help more
people than he can imagine and so using
this as a basis on the sixth day we just
welcomed before the council and asked to
make a choice to whether or not he was
going to join the council and solve the
problem of everything however before the
council is able to successfully induct
Reed into their ranks the hall is
besieged by unseen forces switching to
one of the Reed's who makes mention that
the bridge of the multiverse has been
compromised what we're told is that a
member of the council had stumbled into
the earth for to 8/0 reality and
discovered that the Celestials of that
universe had become mad with power
instead of serving to explore and
experiment the Celestials instead use
their combined abilities to destroy the
realities versions of Galactus eternity
and the other cosmic entities after
which they forced the inhabitants of the
universe to worship them and so as this
video winds down taking the council
member and accessing his mind through
telepathy the Celestials learned of the
council's existence and launched an
attack with the intention of expanding
their sphere of influence to all
realities
so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
instead of writing out a script for this
what I want to do is have fun with it a
script is usually a good idea if it's
something like the little documentary
thing that I'm doing for a history of
the Marvel Universe but I think with a
story like this that I absolutely love I
think it's easier to just sort of run
through it kind of off the cuff so in
the previous video that I had done on
this we had talked about how following
the events of Civil War Reed Richards
had basically come to this realization
that it was inevitable that humanity
would destroy itself
and so because he was effectively the
smartest person in the world he had
basically taken it upon himself to solve
the problem of everything
now while Hickman doesn't directly give
it to us what he tells us is that
somewhere along the line Reed had
developed a multi-dimensional bridge
meaning he could access other dimensions
and other universes and that after he
had done this he had begun speaking with
disembodied voices but didn't really
know who he was talking to but after
getting in and talking to those
individuals he basically discovered they
were alternate reality versions of
himself who had come together to form
something called the Council of Reed's
which is basically an amalgamation of
all these different versions of Reed
Richards who had all come together to
solve the problem of everything now
we're the first video covered how we
were given a tour of these different
realities and the different steps that
were taken to solve the problem of
everything what Hickman does in this
comic here in issue number 572 is
basically show us how much hubris the
council has and what I mean here is that
where hubris is basically just excessive
pride or extreme arrogance what
Hickman's telling us is that because all
these different versions of Reed
Richards had taken it upon themselves to
solve the problem of everything they
effectively saw themselves as fixtures
everything was within their ability to
fix but with these Celestials that
appear from the earth for to aid zero
reality we learned that's not the case
now in the last video we had talked
about how these Celestials hailed from a
universe where they had gone mad with
power instead of just being explorers
and chroniclers of science and
technology like in the current Marvel
Universe they had come to the conclusion
that because they were so powerful they
should rule that universe the mad
Celestials that come together and wiped
out that universes version of eternity
and the other cosmic entities and then
forced the inhabitants of that universe
to begin worshipping the Celestials and
so while one of these versions of read
was housed within that reality and
exploring he had stumbled across the
Celestials and in turn the Celestials
basically took apart his mind read his
thoughts and discovered the existence of
the council and looked to use the
various dimensional portals of this
council of reeds to access other
realities and essentially take over the
multiverse and so what this does is this
picks up with those particular series of
events and it shows us that the
Celestials are essentially laying waste
to everyone and what I mean is that none
of these reads stand a chance now this
is very very important here and the
reason why this is a big deal is because
while these reads are running for
weapons and different things like that
one of the first questions we would ask
is that if three of these reads have
infinity gauntlets why can't they use
them well like we saw in the last video
the Infinity gauntlets can only be used
in the reality that they hail from and
because the Council of reeds is located
in this place outside of all time and
space the gauntlets don't natively work
there and so what happens is that one of
the Reed Richards who has an Infinity
Gauntlet speaks to another version of
Reed whose body is essentially a portal
to his native dimension and so the reed
with the Infinity Gauntlet sticks his
hand into the portal which basically
allows him to just dip his toe so to
speak into his own reality and by virtue
of that used the Infinity Gauntlet but
what's really funny about this is that
it still doesn't work because the mad
Celestials appear to be so powerful
whether it's because they evolve
differently or they absorb other
individuals is it made clear but because
of the power that they possess even if
only a handful are wiped out more just
keep coming
now what Hickman is indirectly telling
us is that because the Celestials in the
main Marvel Universe exist by way of
literally planting their seeds in
planets and then allowing the Celestials
to emerge in those planets Galactus was
most likely destroyed when the mad
Celestials took over meaning there was
no one to consume the planets to keep
the Celestials from being born and so
the result is that these Celestials most
likely took over the reality not in just
power but in sheer population and so
what the mad Celestials laying waste to
the council and the main earth-616 Reed
Richards making his escape he travels
back to the Baxter building closes the
portal barely making it out alive and
begins grabbing up different
in armament now what I want to do here
is I want to sidetrack away from what
Reed Richards is doing for a second and
I want to focus on Franklin and valaria
now this is not wildly important for the
events that are transpiring with the
MADD Celestials but it will be important
later on and the reason why is because
all of this is basically about Franklin
Richards the entirety of Hickman's run
is literally about Franklin Richards I
know it doesn't seem like it now but as
we get further into this and we start
seeing Franklin Richards from the future
we'll begin to see just how important
these events are to his character and so
what we're basically seeing is Franklin
and valaria just kind of enjoying
themselves messing around with the
different artifacts around the Baxter
building now for those of you guys who
are not familiar valaria is a character
who is wildly intelligent in fact she's
about as intelligent as both Reed
Richards and dr. doom despite the fact
that she's just a child and of course
Franklin Richards has the power to work
reality but something that I want you
guys to take note of here is that in
this story and within this point in
Marvel's timeline Franklin Richards had
already lost his powers they had been
burned out and they had been since the
original Abraxas saga when he
resurrected Galactus and destroyed
Abraxas now if you guys are interested
we can have a discussion on that at some
future point in time but all we really
need to know is that at this point in
the story Franklin cannot work reality
he really can't do anything he's
effectively just a normal boy now at
this point we go back to Reed Richards
as he's gathering different arms and
armament together and we actually pick
up with Susan's storm now again this
element of Susan and the element of
Franklin and valaria is gonna be
important in the next couple pages and
the reason for this is that in the
previous events in the last video we had
talked about how Susan and Reed had had
some bit of a falling out and this was
due to the fact that Reed was just
constantly preoccupied he basically
wasn't paying attention to his family
and within Marvel Comics Susan storm is
very family-oriented she's effectively
the person that seems to be holding
everything together and so from her
perspective because Reed seems so
isolated and so removed from her and the
children as well as Johnny Storm and Ben
Grimm it seems as though Reed doesn't
care about them now the reason why this
is important is because as we transition
back to the Council of Reed's with Reed
Richards travelling back to try to get
everybody all the arms they need to
defeat the Celestials while they are
successful in doing this once the
conflict is over we end up finding out
there's a much darker side to the
Council of reeds and what I mean here is
that in addition to the council going
through and essentially lobotomizing all
these different versions of dr. doom who
had displayed evil that just simply
couldn't be corrected we also learned
that these versions of Reed had all
given up their families from the
dimensions that they hail from in order
to solve the problem of everything
it requires the totality of their mind
and the totality of their focus and the
result was that they basically abandoned
their families now this point right here
is the entire crux of this story and
this is why the end result of everything
is so important and so if there's
nothing else that you remember from this
story please remember this one thing but
the way that we learned this is that
what the version of Reed Richards who
had accidentally run into the math
Celestials and initiated this entire
conflict in the first place
his conversation with the main earth-616
version of Reed tells us that as time
progressed as they began to move away as
he spent less and less time with his
family
Susan's storm from his reality began to
get angry and eventually walked away
from him the children Franklin Richards
and valaria Richards did the same thing
Johnny Storm Ben Grimm it was all the
same process in addition to this that
reality's version of Captain America the
Avengers all the earth superheroes
slowly began to forget about Reed
Richards to the point that he didn't
exist or people didn't know who he was
and so even if you were to go back they
probably wouldn't recall him with the
exception of his closest family members
who probably wouldn't want to have
anything to do with him and so when the
earth-616 version of Reed is confronted
with this information he immediately
says no he says absolutely not there's
no way he's going to abandon his family
for the sake of trying to solve the
problem of everything because for him
it's too important now again this is
wildly important this is very very
significant this this these first few
issues are really the foundation for
everything which is why I keep stressing
how important they are now the reason
why Reed Richards chose to stay with his
family is explained to us when we get
another flashback with his father
Nathanael now this is actually a point
that's kind of been dipped on
occasionally over the course of Marvel
Comics but not really on the previous
video we had talked about how Nathaniel
Richards the father of Reed was
basically absent
he throughout his childhood while there
were moments where Nathaniel Richards
had traveled and appeared and made his
presence known to Reed Richards and even
engaged with him a little while for the
most part Reed grew up without a dad and
the result is that he knows how it feels
to not have a father and so for him to
be given the option or to be told that
he has to do the same thing his father
did and abandoned his family in order to
solve the problem of everything for him
it just doesn't work
he can't square that circle and so what
we find is that he begins to reflect on
his experiences of a Ben Grimm and
Johnny Storm his love for Susan storm
but he also keeps the advice that his
father gave him to be a better man than
he was to be a better father to be a
better husband and so once Reed comes to
this realization he effectively steps
out of his office
and begins to reconnect with Susan storm
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end
we're gonna wrap things up and what
we'll actually find in the next video is
that the Fantastic Four from Hickman's
run it's actually going to start tying
in to other events and while a lot of
this isn't wildly important we're gonna
go ahead and cover it anyway just
because there's a few things that pop up
here and there there are again going to
contribute to the larger story and
towards the end events regarding the
adult version of Franklin Richards
returning to the past as so as we
continue our discussion on Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four we picked up
now with issue number 574 and what I
want to do at least what I've done in
the last video is in the description I
actually put a reading list as well as a
link to where you can buy this on
comiXology because to be quite frank
with you guys these videos I think will
be entertaining if you haven't read the
Fantastic Four from Jonathan Hickman but
it's also something that I suggest you
read on your own just because you can do
it illegally pace and there'll be a
couple things here in there that I'll be
required to pass over but because the
story is so good again this is something
I highly suggest you guys buy but with
this particular comic we actually start
out with the birthday of Franklin
Richards now this is why I love Jonathan
Hickman's story so much because he
doesn't forget the small things and what
I mean here is that what the Fantastic
Four being Marvel's original superhero
team they've been around for decades and
their stories have seen a multitude of
different things take place they've done
everything from fight street-level
heroes to take on Galactus in deal with
cosmic and even multiversal level
threats there was even a story where the
Fantastic Four went beyond the
multiverse and visited the one above all
which is the comic a lot of people
reference when they say that the one
above all is Jack Kirby
but with Jonathan Hickman he reminds us
that despite the fact that they've done
these incredible things they're still
human
they're so on a basic level people they
have thoughts they have feelings they
have emotions they have children to take
care of and with Franklin Richards this
is especially important and the reason
why I think this matters so much is with
Franklin as a character most anyone
who's ever read anything about Marvel
Comics or has a passing interest has
looked at the character of Franklin and
been enamoured by the powers that he
possesses as a child he's effectively
able to control the Marvel Universe
depending on who you talk to he's
actually the reason why characters don't
age but with the abilities that he
displays it's very easy to look over the
fact that he's still a kid and so with
this birthday issue what we get is
valyrian Richards giving Franklin
Richards a present but then also
revealing that this birthday party is a
surprise birthday party now again with
this whole celebration we see a mishmash
of different characters show up and what
we don't need to go through all of them
some of the characters that seem to
appear here are both powerpack as well
as leach now with power pack for those
of you guys who don't know there was a
point in time where Marvel was reaching
out to the younger audience space and I
don't mean teenagers actually mean
little kids and what they did is they
created a superhero team called power
pack which included Franklin Richards
but also had various other heroes
involved now I've got a video on power
pack I believe that you're welcome to
check out and if I have that video I'll
post it in the description but with the
character of leach in my mind I think
he's actually one of Marvel's most
powerful mutants by his very nature
leach is what's called a Morlock meaning
he has a physical deformity which keeps
him from being able to live on the
surface and instead he lives in the
tunnels but the power of leech is to
actually shut off the powers of other
people and as far as we know in Marvel
Comics there's no limit to this and so
it could be that he could take on
apocalypse and some would just shut off
apocalypse his action as to his powers
of an immortality different things like
that he could take on someone with
st. abilities whether or not he could
stop Jean Grae from being the Phoenix
it's something we don't know and I don't
think that situations ever been explored
although I would be interested to see
that comic but Liege is very formidable
just because of the fact that he can
turn off other people's abilities but in
addition to this and something that I
also like you guys to take note of here
is Spider Man one of the funny gags with
this is that Ben Grimm basically
introduces all the children to Spider
Man and they react exactly the way we
would expect them to the kids say that's
not Spider Man you know and of course
the real Peter Parker shows up but the
reason why this matters is I would like
you to pay particular attention to how
Franklin Richards relates to spider-man
because there is a beautifully written
issue later on in this story where
Franklin Richards spends time with
spider-man and we get some very in-depth
views into how Peter Parker views his
life after the death of Uncle Ben but
this relates to the fact that Johnny
Storm will actually die later on which
is kind of a spoiler here but that of
course takes place during the
annihilation storyline which again will
tie in here in a little bit but with
Franklin Richards spending time with
spider-man they just kind of hang out
and there's really not a whole lot to go
on here not a whole lot to celebrate of
course he takes him on a on a ride
through the town which happens off panel
we don't really see that but was the two
of them returned we see a little bit of
banter back and forth between Peter
Parker and Johnny Storm and this again
if those of you guys who were currently
reading the the spider-man run is where
a lot of this stuff yells from even
though they're not necessarily the best
of friends at this point in time they
are still extremely good friends and so
as we continue on with our run of of
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four with
issue 574 but we actually pick up later
on that night and this is where the
story gets cool what happens is because
the technology of the Fantastic Four
allows them to basically monitor
everything that goes on within and
without the back ship building on a
global scale the building is met with a
time quake condition red now while
hitman doesn't tell us exactly what this
means we can basically just infer that
somebody is opening a portal somewhere
and indeed that's exactly what happens
but the individual that shows up
completely incapacitated Fantastic Four
now while he doesn't necessarily beat
them he puts up a force field that they
can't get past and when I was reading
this I was like oh my
who is this guy like what's going on
here and we don't find out until later
on but what happens is while Susan storm
tries to get past this while Reed
Richards puts his mind to the test
Ben Grimm tries to pummel through it
there's nothing they can do but more
notably whenever they punch a hole
through a wall to try to get around it
the force field expands to fill that
hole so they're basically never ever
going to get through but from here we
see Franklin Richards as a child
actually sent out into the hallway
trying to figure out what's happening
now again one thing to keep in mind here
is that Franklin doesn't have powers
he's just a young kid he's just a boy
and so while the Fantastic Four call out
to this guy and try to get him to stop
he murmurs something to Franklin
Richards and effectively lifts him into
the air now from here the man goes into
the bedroom of Valyria Richards now
again valaria is a character who is
wildly intelligent in the realm of
Marvel Comics in fact she is right up
there with Reed Richards and dr. doom
and it's probably one of the smartest
people probably the number one smartest
person on the planet when everything's
taken into account and in fact during
Hickman's run of secret Wars a valaria
Richards was the one that came to the
conclusion that the incursions cannot be
stopped
Reed Richards didn't come to that
conclusion first it was actually her now
Reed of course didn't want to listen to
it he wanted to preserve his reality but
at the end of it all he had to accept
her calculations as being absolutely
true
but what this man says to Valyria
Richards is that the future must be
avoided at all costs now again this is
classic Jonathan Hickman this is really
just him telling us stuff and we have no
clue what's going on so if you feel
yourself being confused don't feel bad
it's the nature of Hickman stories but
all of this will begin to make sense as
things go on now what he says to her is
that there will be a war between the
four cities and that those who died
cannot be forgotten now this is
something that I really want you to pay
attention to because the next thing he
tells her is that all hope lies with dr.
doom and this is the craziest thing this
is the craziest situation but again all
of this will be made to make sense but
when is it up happening is as he begins
to make his way out he begins to leave
valaria catches up with him and she says
happy birth
which tells us this is the adult version
of Franklin Richards and so once
everything begins to calm down once this
version vanishes and the portal
disappears and Reed Richards Ben Grimm
Johnny Storm and Susan storm get with
the kids and they basically put them
back to bed the conversation becomes who
is that guy and why was he able to shut
everything down now for here we also
take note of the fact that valaria
Richards has her own little calculations
on how does not the problem everything
and while this isn't very important
right now this will be very important
later on but more notably than this what
we learn is that the words that the
adult Franklin Richards muttered to his
younger self was to rest and remember
who he was and this is why I love the
story so much I love this comic because
what's happened here is the adult
Franklin Richards has woken up the
powers of his younger self now will
actually learn later on that other
things are happening that he actually
mentioned other things to him and we'll
learn there's a lot more to the
situation than what's initially being
revealed to us but because Franklin
Richards powers have been restored to
him the first thing he does is create a
pocket universe and the bedroom of his
room now how awesome is that if with
that being said guys I really hope you
feel the excitement in this comic
because this is such a cool story and it
really only gets better from here it
just keeps going up and up and up and it
leads to this amazing finale so as we
continue our discussion on Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four what we do here
is we actually tie in to the events of
old man Logan now this is really cool
because a lot of people don't know that
the Fantastic Four from Jonathan Hickman
tied it into old man Logan and actually
followed up to it and told us what
happened
after the story came to an end now
somebody to keep in mind is that The
Secret Wars version of old man Logan
actually reckoned this information from
Hickman's Fantastic Four and so this
information in the in Hickman's run
isn't really applicable anymore for
those of you guys who don't know retcon
is retroactive continuity that means
that somebody goes in and changes things
removes things and so because the old
man Logan Secret Wars event had
basically provided new information this
information here isn't really relevant
anymore with regards to the larger
Marvel Universe but for the sake of our
discussion and Hickman's
of the Fantastic Four we can use this
because it still self-contained and
it'll be very important to understanding
the things that happen later on down the
line but for those of the eyes who never
read old man Logan this was a story that
was written as an alternate universe
that basically depicted a world where
the supervillains had taken over
everything what did it up happening here
is that because humanity and superheroes
were not necessarily as powerful as the
villains there were always a multitude
of circumstances whereby the villains
could have taken over but the reason why
they didn't was because they could never
work together they had their own agendas
they were infighting they wanted to
destroy their own nemec's or maybe
they'd assembly wanted to take over the
world but for whatever reason they
thought only about themselves and they
weren't thinking about other things and
so what ended up happening here is that
within the realm within the universe of
old man Logan under the leadership of
the Red Skull the super villains of the
world launched multiple attacks against
the superheroes of the world at the same
time meaning the Fantastic Four the
Avengers the Inhumans the x-men they
were all attacked simultaneously now
these attacks weren't necessarily done
by brute force which is to say the
supervillains didn't just charge
buildings and attack everyone instead
they use stealth they used guile and
they use espionage to achieve their goal
within the realm of old man Logan within
the I guess the context of Wolverine
himself what we're told is that the
Spider Man villain Mysterio had the
ability to create illusions that
manipulated the five senses basically
your your sense of smell touch taste so
on and so forth and so what ends up
happening is Mysterio travels to the
x-men mansion and tricks Wolverine into
believing that the villains of the
Marvel Universe
are attacking the mansion and so
Wolverine goes through and kills every
last one of them but once the illusion
is revealed we learn that Wolverine had
actually killed all of the x-men and
because of his healing factor all their
attacks to him did no damage and so with
Wolverine realizing what it is that he's
done he actually goes into a state of
isolation and refuses to pop his claws
again now following Wolverines time away
his superheroes began getting killed off
by the supervillains until there was no
one left to stop the supervillains from
taking over the world now what we're
only told what goes on within the
context of the United States and what we
is that the country itself was divided
into sections with the red skull taking
over Washington DC and the surrounding
areas in the Northeast and everybody
taking whatever else was left and so
while people like Magneto took over
middle America magneto himself was
killed with his section being taken over
by the campaign but in terms of
Wolverine while he's attended to live a
quiet life he started a family of his
own but he lives under the rule of the
Incredible Hulk
now following the events of these super
villains taking over the world The
Incredible Hulk roofs banner had
actually made it with his cousin
she-hulk because as he explained it she
was the only one that he could procreate
with and so the result was that they
produce a litany of incestuous kids now
were the events during old man Logan
would have Hawkeye show up at the front
door of Wolverine for the purpose of
having Logan accompany him across the
country in an effort to take Super
Soldier Serum to the various underground
resistance groups in New York in order
to improve their efforts to defeat the
super villains with Wolverine being gone
we actually learned that the family of
the Incredible Hulk killed his family
and so once the entire effort of the
resistance movement is shown to have
been a ruse by the Red Skull for the
purpose of eliminating what was left of
the superhero community when Wolverine
gets back home he finds out that his
entire family has been killed by Bruce
banners family and so in response he
pops his claws for the first time in
something like 50 years and kills the
Incredible Hulk as well as virtually
everybody else in his family save for
the Incredible Hulk son Hulk jr. now
we're old man Logan ended with Wolverine
taking hold jr. and riding off into the
sunset we didn't know how things ended
we didn't necessarily know what came
next
with Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
it follows up to that what we're told is
that following this Wolverine he
basically initiated a giant resistance
group bringing together various humans
and what was left of the superhero
community that was in hiding and led a
revolution against all the supervillains
of the world killing them all and taking
the planet back and so where humanity
spent the next several decades even the
next hundred years basically going
through and rebuilding itself about 500
years after the events of old man Logan
ended Galactus returned and tried to
consume the planet now by this time hope
jr. is old any
actually looks almost identical to the
maestro from The Incredible Hulk stories
which you'll find down in the
description of this video but what we
learn is that the remaining superheroes
are those superheroes who have began
developing new powers and mutants who
have emerged basically leading attack
against Galactus but a multitude of them
are completely obliterated by the power
that Galactus possesses now while
Galactus is defeated because he's
basically killed ones up happening is
hope jr. alongside various other
individuals began terraforming Galactus
turning him into an object that can be
used to travel into the past for the
purpose of preserving humanity and the
reason why is because as time progressed
whether the planet had been consumed by
Galactus or not it was going to become
uninhabitable for a variety of reasons
and humanity would simply cease to exist
and so what this does is this actually
jumps back to the present day and we
pick up with the Fantastic Four
alongside a relatively new character
named Alyssa Moy now Alyssa Moy was
introduced as part of Mark Miller's run
on the Fantastic Four
prior to Johnathan Hickman's run and
what Alyssa Moy was established as being
was the girlfriend or I guess the
ex-girlfriend of Reed Richards prior to
his marriage to Susan storm and Alyssa
Moy is actually as smart as Reed
Richards is and so the conclusion that
Alyssa Moy came to was that by virtue of
terraforming by virtue of pollution a
multitude of other problems the earth at
some point in the future would become
uninhabitable now this does not mean
that Alyssa Moy knew that old man Logan
was going to happen in fact old man
Logan is now an alternate reality so
that future will not happen but because
of the fact that she believes that the
earth is going to become uninhabitable
at some point in time she alongside a
man named Ted Castle who's also as
intelligent as Reed Richards had
developed something called new world and
this was basically an artificially
created planet earth that would exist so
that when the time came that the normal
earth was not habitable anymore humanity
could move from the normal earth to new
earth and lived there and so what ends
up happening is once Hulk jr. and those
various forces from the future travel
into the past in an effort to save
humanity they encounter resistance from
the Fantastic Four who don't want their
planet to be destroyed before it needs
to be and so what happens here is once a
conflict began
to quell once the Fantastic Four and
Hulk jr. and the various other forces
begin to talk things out and realize
what's going on ultimately the Fantastic
Four hunt the Incredible Hulk and those
individuals on new world and then send
them on their way now the reason why I
brought this up and the reason why this
matters is that for those of you guys
who were reading time runs out by
Jonathan Hickman the events that led
into secret Wars there was a comic
whereby Captain America obtained the
time Jim and began jumping forward in
the future and there was one instance
where by Ultron had taken over the world
that was not the age of Ultron story
what that was was Alex Ultron during the
events when the Incredible Hulk and
those individuals in the future were
trying to preserve their planet
there was one being named Alex Ultron
who was actually the epitome of the
Ultron program in terms of an individual
meaning that from a time that Ultron was
first created by Hank Pym up until that
point in time Alex Ultron represented
the peak of the Ultron programming and
so what ends up happening is that once
they're set on new world and they're
sent off along their way Alex Ultron
begins to evolve and begins to grow to
the point where it actually goes out on
its own and then creates a planet Ultron
in and of itself and then eventually
comes back to earth and tries to take
things over again now again that was an
alternate reality but I just wanted to
bring that up because I wanted to show
you guys how everything and Jonathan
Hickman's writing is all interconnected
but again we'll get back into Franklin
Richards future self restoring the
powers of his younger self in the next
video because what we're actually gonna
find is there's a lot going on there's
all different kinds of things behind the
scenes and that this is really all just
a story about a son trying to save his
dad
so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four what
I'm thinking is that you guys are gonna
freak as we get to this video because if
you guys are anything like me I was
reading through this comic and I was
like oh my god and this is why I love
Jonathan Hickman writing so much because
god he knows how to help one hell of a
story so in the last video we had talked
about how the old man Logan's story
dealt with the death of all the
superheroes and the supervillains taking
over the world and at the end of that
story
Wolverine had basically taken the son of
the Incredible Hulk as a newborn and
went forward with the intention of
creating a resistance to get rid of all
the supervillains and so what had
happened is in that reality the
supervillains were completely eliminated
and society began to go back to a state
of normalcy but the problem here is that
over time the earth began dying and so
the result was that those individuals in
the future though both superheroes and
normal humans had worked together to
create a portal to create a machine that
would allow them to travel into the past
in order to ensure their survival but in
order to power that machine they had to
take Galactus from the future
kill him and then use his power cosmic
to power the machine and so the result
was that once they achieved that goal
the future body of Galactus had fallen
through the rift and landed in the
present which was discovered by Mole Man
who informed Reed Richards of what was
going on and so what we do is we pick up
with this and that Silver Surfer had
discovered that Reed Richards bury the
body of future Galactus and Silver
Surfer reported back to Galactus what it
was that he had found simply because
this was such an important situation and
so what happens here is that Galactus
from the present simply shows up on the
planet earth and this is so cool because
he doesn't go through a whole bunch of
introductions he doesn't do any
threatening he said we just shows up to
Reed Richards when Reed Richards appears
to me Galactus and Galactus just says
explain and this I think is one of the
perfect examples it's so cool how hitman
takes concepts takes like all these
thoughts and emotions and feelings and
throws them into a simple word because
when Galactus just shows up and says
explain it denotes Authority it denotes
if you don't give me what I want to know
I'm going to destroy your
world I mean it's it's such a cool
series of things that go into this but
what Reed does is he effectively tells
Galactus exactly what I just said a
second ago about the future of the old
man Logan universe and the travel
through time and the result is that Reid
says that for him it just seemed right
to bury that version of Galactus it
didn't seem right to simply just leave
his decaying corpse on the surface of
the world
now while Reid doesn't necessarily say
it either I would imagine that to a
degree there would be panic if for
example the Avengers were just
travelling around the world or if the
x-men were just travelling around the
world doing whatever the Avengers and
the x-men do when they're often and they
stumbled across the decaying corpse of
Galactus on the surface of the planet
they would probably start freaking out
and they would be like oh my god
Galactus is dead and who knows who did
it and it would turn into a great big
huge thing and so it was probably cut
trying to eliminate panic you know more
or less but the fact remains here that
once Galactus is informed of everything
that's going on by Reed he tells the
Silver Surfer to locate the new world
that Reed had put the survivors on and
sent them off to and so one silver
surfer locates a new world he tells
Galactus exactly where it is and
Galactus says that they're immediately
going to leave and they're gonna go find
new world and investigate for themselves
now this is all extremely important and
the reason why is because this deals
directly with Franklin Richards and this
tells us why Galactus is afraid of
Franklin Richards what we find out is
that with Johnny Storm showing up and
trying to figure things out trying to
understand whether or not he needs to
react in a defensive or an office and
capacity when Reed tells Johnny that
he's going to leave with Galactus
there's really no discussion here
there's no debate there's no well let's
talk things out and figure things out
Galactus wants to find out what's going
on Reed's gonna go with him and there's
no two ways about it and so what happens
is that once the two take off once a
Silver Surfer goes with Galactus and
Reed Richards to find out what's going
on in new world we pick up with new
world but something interesting to note
here this is why I say this is all about
Franklin Richards is because when they
arrive Galactus makes mention to read
about how fast he had left earth and
Reed says yes he noticed that but he
figured that if Galactus was leaving the
earth faster than normal do is probably
a reason why and Reed was simply going
to wait and see whether or not that
reason revealed itself but instead
Galactus tells him directly what he says
that he left the planet Earth in order
to avoid a conflict that could have been
catastrophic on a universal scale
meaning it could have laid waste to the
universe and when Reid asked what it is
that Galactus is talking about Galactus
says that the barriers and Franklin
witcher's mine had been removed which of
course was done by his future self and
that Reed and Galactus need to talk
about Franklin now again this is a
really big deal because Galactus says
that he was afraid basically he left the
planet Earth because he was afraid and
by combining those two things together
he left the planet Earth because he was
afraid of facing Franklin Richards now
this doesn't mean that Galactus in and
of himself is terrified of the ability
that someone could have to warp reality
and in fact this really is the case with
Franklin Franklin can warp reality but
it's the fact that Galactus is afraid of
Franklin because of the things he's done
in the past way back in the 1990s during
the Abraxas saga when Galactus was
killed Abraxas took his place but then
Franklin Richards basically resurrected
Galactus from the dead the fact that he
brought back a cosmic entity from the
dead tells us how powerful Franklin is
at the same time Franklin's a child
meaning that his imagination can run
wild he can create and manifest all
kinds of different things that would
wreak havoc on the world as a whole and
it could be the Franklin doesn't know
how to undo those things so he could
manifest some force that would wipe out
the universe entirely and then not be
able to undo that we've never really
seen an instance where that's happened
before but it doesn't mean that it
couldn't now what we don't find out
exactly what it was that Galactus and
Reed Richards talked about instead
Hickman actually just skips over that
now we'll find out exactly what it is
that he's talking about once we see the
mad celestial show up and Franklin
Richards battle them an entire scenario
effectively speaks for itself but more
so than that will actually see Galactus
speaking directly to Franklin Richards
about the power he possesses and what it
is that he's capable of doing and how he
relates to Galactus himself but from
here we basically just show up at new
earth and we see the Galactus and Reed
Richards are talking about everything
that's going on and so where Galactus
initially asked how it was that new
earth was created how it was all this
came into existence again Reed Richards
basically rehashes what we know about
the future of the old man Logan universe
and when Galactus asked whether or not
Reed Richards can prevent this from
happening that is to say he can
actively save that future from coming to
an end Reid begins to reflect on his
time with the with the Council of reeds
and he makes the case that yes most
likely he can solve this problem that
would have resulted in the destruction
of the future the result is that because
Reid what effectively be stopping those
individuals from the future and having
to come to the past in the first place
and initiate this entire series of
events for Galactus this world will
simply cease to exist and so instead of
allowing it to pass instead of allowing
it to basically vanish without any real
advantage Galactus decides to consume it
now one of my favorite things here is
that the occupants of new world
initially protests they say no Galactus
cannot destroy the world and Galactus is
reply is who test God and does not wager
their life a price will be paid and this
is why I love Galactus so much because
this is just a cool thing to say it's
just a cool line to say I like the way
it sounds to be honest with you guys and
I might even make like a wallpaper or
something out of it but I think it's a
really cool moment it's just nothing
really significant here it's just these
are one of the things that I like about
about Hickman's writing and so basically
the people on this planet on new world
are given a chance to leave
what Galactus says is that he is going
to consume the world he's going to end
all of it but instead of simply just
killing all those individuals on new
world what he's gonna do is allowed Reed
Richards to get as many people off the
planet as possible between the time that
Galactus begins consuming his machine in
order to consume the world and the time
that he's done doing that and so from
here what we do is we transition back to
the future of Franklin Richards and we
pick up with his character after he had
woken up the powers of his younger self
now I know this is a lot of
time-traveling I know this is a lot of
bouncing around but these things are
extremely important for understanding
the very end of this story and why
things unfold the way they do what
happens here is we pick up with the
adult Franklin Richards when he simply
arrives in the future and there's
nothing here it's just a giant expanse
of white we don't really know what's
going on here there's no planet there's
no greenery no buildings no nothing it's
just total emptiness and the questions
asked by an individual that we can't see
whether or not Franklin was successful
and what he says is yes he had basically
woken up the powers of his younger self
remove those mental clocks and so now
the younger Franklin Richards has the
power to warp reality
in addition to this the adult Franklin
Richards had told Valyria that all hope
lies in doom now we'll find out why dr.
doom is such an important part of
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four but
what we learn is that the adult version
of Valyria is also here alongside the
adult version of Franklin Richards and
so what we're told is that the entire
basis behind this the entire premise
behind the adult Franklin Richards going
into the past was performed by the
father of Reed Richards Nathanael now
again when we started Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four we had talked about how
the father of Reed Richards Nathaniel
Richards was basically absent he threw
out almost his entire life he didn't
really spend much time talking to his
son because he wasn't there while he was
part of Reed's life when he was very
very young Nathanael had simply just
vanished for reasons that weren't really
explained what Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four does is it basically
fills in the gaps and it simply says
that at this point all they can do is
just see how things unfold now again
this is really just very confusing here
because the indication seems to be met
this future is coming to an end and that
some window some opportunity is
effectively closing with each moment the
passes and this seems to be their
last-ditch effort to ensure that this
future does not come to fruition now
again we don't really know what this
future is we just know that something's
going on and they're trying to keep it
from happening and so while valaria
travels back and she effectively leaves
what franklin richards does as an adult
is he manipulates this pocket reality
this little dementia that he's created
due to the fact that apparently because
the future is coming to an end this is a
safe space that time will change time
will pass but instead things will stay
exactly the way they are the way he's
making them within this small space now
this is all meta textual stuff this is
all meta textual commentary and it can
be a little bit daunting but things will
make sense and the reason why is because
Nathaniel Richards actually jumps into
the past to visit Reed Richards when he
was in college alongside Ben Grimm and
while they were together while they were
spending time with one another what
Nathaniel does is he basically explains
why he was gone for so long but what he
says is that at some point along the
line he and a multitude of other
Nathaniel Richards were pulled into a
singularity to battle some individual
with immense power
and because of this Nathaniel himself
had gained the ability to control time
to manipulate time the downside to this
was that in the far distant future time
itself was controlled by a man named
immortus and it was monitored by the
time variance authority meaning that
individuals who meddle with time are
strictly punished and so the result is
that because both Nathaniel Richards
from the main Marvel Universe and all
the other alternate reality versions of
Nathaniel had all developed the ability
to manipulate time after battling this
foe they were all brought forward to
immortus and they were basically
instructed that not all of them can have
his power only one of them can but
because the power is part of them on a
genetic level it can't be removed
meaning the only way to ensure that only
one of them can have the power is to
eliminate every version of methane
Richards except for one and so what this
did is it initiated something called the
great hunt and it was basically all
these different versions of Nathaniel
Richards from across the cosmos hunting
each other down and trying to kill each
other and so for those of you guys who
read spider-verse and you followed the
events with the inheritors chasing down
all the different versions of spider-man
and spider-woman from across the
multiverse this is the equivalent of
that except it would be as if all the
spider-man were hunting each other down
and so one is up happening is Nathaniel
petitions Reed Richards to basically
help him take care of the last version
of Nathaniel so that the existing the
main Marvel Universe's annual Richards
will be the last one left now while Reed
himself is extremely intelligent during
his college years he's nowhere near as
intelligent as Doctor Doom now this will
change over time due to the fact that
dr. Doom's arrogance will actually get
the better of him but at the moment Reed
is still smart but doom knows a little
bit more about both technology and the
ability to manipulate time and so what
ends up happening is Nathaniel Richards
and Ben Grimm and Reed Richards and
Doctor Doom from the past from our
college years basically travel back into
the future and they encounter this
second to last remaining version of
Nathaniel this evil version of himself
now where this isn't super important
where this isn't necessarily the most
important thing coming out of the story
it actually is the basis for why
Franklin Richards is doing the things
that he's doing and what we find out
here is that with these versions of
Nathaniel battling one another
ultimately it all comes down to this
very notion that Nathaniel is going to
be the last one left he essentially
kills all the other versions of himself
and so with these two versions of
Nathaniel Richards battling one another
the conflict essentially goes exactly
the way that we would suspect in the
sense that there's some give-and-take
there's the possibility that the main
version of Nathaniel Richards will lose
but ultimately he ends up coming out on
top with the help of Reed Richards Ben
Grimm and Doctor Doom from the past and
so while they're successful in killing
this other version of himself
Nathaniel Richards is basically the last
one left now the main version of
Nathaniel Richards is the only iteration
of himself now having said that what we
do now is we pick up with Nathaniel
traveling back to the future to meet
Franklin Richards and this is extremely
important and if there's nothing else
that you remember from the story please
remember this what is up happening here
is that Franklin begins to talk with
Nathaniel and he asks him were you
successful in killing that other version
of yourself and Nathaniel says yes and
so the result is that Franklin says
perfect and destroys the reality around
Nathaniel and what this does is it tells
us that Nathaniel himself is almost
powerless to stop everything that's
going on that he doesn't even really
understand why it is that Franklin's
doing this and what Franklin says is
that one he disabled the ability of
Nathaniel to use his own powers by
controlling both reality around him and
manipulating his brain but also that
when Nathaniel engaged in the great hunt
and began killing off all the other
versions of himself that he made all
those alternate reality versions of Reed
Richards fatherless and the reason why
this is a big deal is because in our
earlier versions of Hickman's run of
Fantastic Four we had talked about how
those alternate reality versions of Reed
Richards had created the Council of
reeds and abandoned their families
because they didn't have the guidance of
their fathers and the reason they didn't
have the guidance of their fathers is
because this great hunt took place and
their fathers were killed off and so
what Franklin is doing here is he's not
really gaining revenge on Nathaniel he's
basically saying that Nathaniel
in Anor himself is the reason why all
this happened in the first place and so
what we do and something you may have
noticed is we were going through this
comic is we actually saw some discussion
between valaria and Susan and we pick up
with that while there is a lot of fluff
that goes on in the two of them talking
which is really just a mother relating
to her daughter where at least valaria
relating to her mother
in her younger form not everything that
happens here is extremely important and
in fact the only thing that's really
important is what she says to Susan
storm at the end what valaria tells her
is that when everything seems like it's
darkest when everything seems like it's
going to end and all hope seems to be
gone that Susan storm is going to have
to hold on she's going to have to keep
fighting despite the fact that the
circumstances seem bleak but at the
moment that she does that at the time
when everything seems like it's going to
crack and it's gonna fall to pieces that
something will come to save her now we
find out what that something is again at
the end of this story I know it seems
really really wild but uh but this yeah
it's it's it's awesome what happens I'm
almost inclined to spoil it because I've
done it before but I don't I don't
really want to those of you guys who
have read Hickman stand asking for it
please don't spoil this please don't
tell people what happens but in the end
winds up happening is that Phil area
effectively departs as things begin to
come to a close she takes off and she
goes back with Franklin Richards and
what we find out is that something had
happened in the past that began this
wave of destruction throughout the
multiverse and the multiverse itself was
effectively collapsing and this pocket
universe that Franklin had made was
designed to keep space-time separate
from around them but the issue with this
is that Franklin himself can warp
reality but in order for him to be able
to warp it he has to be in control of it
and the issue is that if reality is
operating outside of his control he
can't do anything to stop it his powers
effectively work against him and that
seems to be what's happening here and so
is the two of them begin to get sucked
into this rift what is up happening is
they jump through and then we actually
won't see or hear from them until the
very end of this story but with that
being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end let me go let
me know what you guys think about about
Hickman's fent Hazzard for again as of
the last video I know this can be a
little bit daunting and things will
actually be a lot easier to understand
going forward but again I promise
all of this will make sense once we get
to the end and that's the nature of a
Hickman story
Hickman stories draw threads from all
over the place they pull threads from
everywhere and nothing seems to make
sense but then at the very very end he
writes a single comic that wraps all
that stuff up and then you just get the
light bulb effect
oh I understand what he was doing that's
exactly what is up happening
don't worry guys everything will make
sense at the end of this which will
probably happen in the next three or
four videos or so we've got a few more
things to cover especially with a death
of Johnny Storm in the future of Ben
Grimm but aside from that we can
actually sort of jump towards the end
and then just fill things in according
to whatever seems to be interesting as
so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four we
pick up now with the Fantastic Four
issue number 579 now this I guess this
and issue number 580 these are what we
call filler issues these are not wildly
important to the overall happenings of
hitman's Fantastic Four but the reason
why we're covering them is because there
are events that will transpire later on
in his run of the Fantastic Four that
will require us to know about this the
first is that spider-man will become
part of the events but also Doctor Doom
will become part of the events but the
other half of this is that Hickman is
going to launch a story called the
future foundation and the Future
Foundation will basically be a tie-in to
his run of the Fantastic Four and it'll
be like Batman with Detective Comics
where it gives us the other half of
what's going on with regards to the
events as they're transpiring now with
this story what we're told is that Reed
Richards has journeyed to Golden
Colorado to pick up with something
called the singularity conference now
the singularity conference does actually
exist I wouldn't say this is something
like TED talk but as far as I understand
it is basically a research conference it
involves some of the top minds that
focus on artificial intelligence now
again I'm not really knowledgeable about
it so I can't offer too much on that
discussion but what I can say is that
within the Marvel Universe as far as
Jonathan Hickman's run of the Fantastic
Four is concerned the the singularity
conference was created by Reed Richards
in Marvel Comics and he was designed for
the purpose of bringing the world's top
scientific minds together to basically
solve the world's problems to move the
world in a more progressive and prolific
direction but the issue here is that
Reed Richards has yet to see this
conference to do this and what I mean is
that as he's talking to them of course
he praises she-hulk for the fact that
you know being in the legal profession
she's basically written articles about
the laws of artificial intelligence and
about the laws of technology and how
they relate to what goes on in the world
at the moment before Reed this was
designed to genuinely be a technological
masterpiece but instead of being that
the individuals who were part of the
singularity conference have basically
allowed their politics to run the show
instead of writing articles and instead
of focusing on is artificial
intelligence a realistic goal or our
advances in technology a realistic goal
is turned into an argument of our is
artificial intelligence and its
technology are those realistic goals
insofar as their political views about
religion and I guess you know various
social issues around the country and the
result is that reads basically come to
the belief that they've all failed at
their their task they've all failed a
conference and they failed their purpose
and so what Reed Richards ends up doing
is he doesn't really does disassemble
the entire concept of the singularity
conference instead he leaves he
basically quits he walks away and says
that everything is all said and done and
so the following week what we do is we
pick up with his arrival back at the
Baxter building now we're not really
told what he was doing during this time
and we don't really need to know but
what is important here is that after
talking to Johnny storm after talking to
the various members of the Fantastic
Four and just kind of associating with
them and being welcomed back what we're
told is that he's basically reached out
to the smartest people or the smartest
children and the in the Marvel Universe
so he's reached out to his own children
Franklin and valaria now I wouldn't say
Franklin is one of the smartest people
in the world but because of the fact
that he's a child of Reed Richards of
course Reed Richards is going to bring
his son into the fold but valaria as we
discussed is genuinely extremely
intelligent she's as smart as Reed
Richards if not smarter depending on
what it is that's going on but the
reason why she has the edge and the
reason why all these other kids are
brought in as part of the part of this
this group is because they have
imagination they're not restricted by
politics they're not restricted by how
they want the world to be restricted
they're restricted by how they look at
the world and so to them there is no
limit anything can happen anything can
be done and this is exactly what Reed
was looking for and so after talking to
these various individuals after talking
to the various students and Wyndham
asking the question why are they all
there what Reed says is that they are
the future foundation they're there to
basically help him solve the problem of
everything but more so than that to
basically look to the future to look to
the horizon and to move the world into a
better direction now the reason why I
brought this up this is actually kind of
a sub
this is a side-story this actually will
be pretty interesting later on down the
line and it will tie in to Reed's
failing in attempting to solve the
problem of everything it's basically the
events of Ben Grimm for those of you
guys who have looked at Ben Grimm
historically as a character that's
routinely been a part of the Fantastic
Four and always fought alongside them
you may see him in a couple different
ways you may see him as a character
who's basically just kind of the comedic
relief he cracks his jokes and he calls
it a day you may look at him as the
strong guy of the team he basically is
the hired not really the hired muscle
he's basically the the muscle of the
team he does what the other members of
the team can do when it comes to sheer
strength but one of the major
cornerstones of Ben Grimm's character is
that he's always struggled with the fact
that he can never go back to the way he
was before now there have been attempts
made by Reed Richards to basically cure
him but they've always failed and in
some in some instances they've been
catastrophic in the sense that they've
completely changed the way Ben Grimm
looks at in fact if you go look at some
of the John Byrne artistry on the
Fantastic Four there was one point in
time whereby his physical appearance
became very edgy and very rocky in the
sense that instead of looking kind of
smooth the way he does now he had a lot
of sharp edges and the reason why is
because that was a result of Reed
Richards meddling around and attempting
to cure him and so what happens here is
the first task of the future foundation
is to try to cure Ben Grimm and this is
one of the coolest things about this
because this is Hickman basically
telling us that again
these kids have unbridled imagination
there's no limit to what they can do but
more so than that they're better working
as a group than they are as individuals
and this again highlights the limit of
Reed Richards Reed Richards is just one
man he can only look at the world
through his own eyes but with a group of
kids who have unlimited imagination
putting their minds to task they can
effectively solve anything
and what we find out is that valaria
begins speaking with Ben Grimm and they
initially present the idea of returning
him back to his human form of basically
making him normal again but Ben Grimm
again shied away from it just because of
his checkered past with Reed Richards
attend me to do this and so what we're
told by both Franklin and valaria and a
couple other kids is that the problem
with Reed Richards trying to cure Ben
Grimm is he wasn't looking at Ben Grimm
for what he was he was looking at Ben
Grimm's entire change as something on
the surface as opposed to a fundamental
change and this is actually really cool
because Hickman gives us a little bit of
modification on the powers of the
Fantastic Four but for the longest time
when the Fantastic Four had their
abilities Reed Richards stretching
Johnny Storm being able to you know set
himself on fire and so on and so forth
you know we always had this notion that
maybe it was just something that read
and that Susan storm and that Johnny
storm could control they tapped into
some aspect of their brain and they were
able to manifest these things but what
the what hitman tells us the through the
Future Foundation is that this is not
the case that basically Johnny Storm
Susan storm and Reed Richards have like
an on/off switch for their powers but
there's still a genetic part of who they
are so when it comes down to the very
fundamental the core level of of the
Fantastic Four in a lot of ways they're
no different than the x-men and the only
difference here is that instead of a
gene activating that caused their powers
instead there are their bodies were
modified on the on the genetic level and
so the result is that Ben Grimm does not
have this on/off switch he doesn't have
the ability to modify his genetic code
and so what Franklin Richards and more
valaria Richards and the rest of the
Future Foundation do is they basically
say that they've come up with a way for
him to do this they've come up with a
way for him to effectively turn his
power off and what they do is they
present him with a with a substance with
a chemical of sorts that he can consume
and that will make him human for only
one week now this is extremely important
and the reason why is because in the
next video and what we're actually gonna
do in the next few discussions or so is
one we're gonna talk about the death of
Johnny Storm but - once we get further
into this and we actually get into
nathaniel richards visiting Reed
Richards again we're gonna learn that
there's actually a lot more to this
substance and not only is it going to
make Ben Grimm human for a week it's
actually going to have unforeseen
consequences and this is gonna you know
again be Hickman's way of telling us
that Reed Richards doesn't know
everything and despite the fact that he
has a future foundation and despite the
fact that these kids are all working
together in the end they're actually
going to screw up the life of Ben Grimm
they're going to you know they're going
to basically destroy it Ben Grimm
doesn't know it they don't know it and
they won't know it for a little while
but it's actually a really cool series
of events and it's actually really
interesting the way this whole this
whole little bit unfolds and again I
really consider this to be just a great
element of hickman storytelling it's
just a cornerstone of storytelling this
thread doesn't go anywhere it just shows
us how things will turn out in a future
point in time however following this
we do is we pick up with valaria
Richards a short time later when she
goes to visit Doctor Doom now this
little bit of the story actually
requires some expansion on a few
previously existing concepts they're not
wildly important but they give us an
idea of what's going on during an event
called the fall of hooks which dealt
with a group called the Intelligencia
what we were told is that at some point
prior to most of the large events have
been going on in Marvel Comics some of
these smartest super villains in the
history of Marvel Comics had basically
banded together as a sort of Illuminati
esque team of their own and they had
planned world domination and different
things like that but they were
responsible for the creation of Red Hulk
and so on and so forth but the fact
remains that dr. doom had been a part of
their plan to basically take over
everything
but during this conflict as part of fall
of Hawks alpha dr. doom had been
captured alongside Reed Richards and a
handful of other superheroes who were
considered to be the top eight smartest
individuals on the planet Earth which is
actually where that list comes from
people talk about the smartest
individuals of Marvel Comics and what
had happened was dooms intelligence had
effectively been siphoned off now we
didn't initially know this and in fact
we didn't really know the outcome of it
all we knew was that doom had seemed to
have been shaken up by everything that
was going on and so what happens is that
as Valyria Richards is making her way
out of the Baxter building she stumbles
across the laboratory of Reed Richards
and the portal that he created did
granted him access to the council of
Reed's and what happens is she basically
begins going over the holographic logs
of Reed Richards where he talks about
everything that had happened and what
valaria learns is that not only was Reed
trying to solve the problem of
everything but she also learns that he
that she can basically access this
particular portal and so what happens
here and this actually takes place off
panel though we find out later on what
Isle has taken place
she basically accesses the portal and so
what happens is that once she's done she
leaves and she comes back to converse
with dr. doom now once we pick up with
doom he's basically reflecting on how
his intelligence had been siphoned away
by the Intelligencia and because the
fact that he's partially damaged he
basically reaches out for the purpose of
taking his adopted son Christoph Bernard
and assimilating the intelligence of
Christoph Renard and in turn basically
using him to restore himself now this
tells us how sinister and how dark
Doctor Doom is but it also makes him
really cool I can't tell you exactly why
but there's something to be said about
Doctor Doom willing to just kill
innocent people for the purpose of
ensuring his own legacy of ensuring that
he continues on but before this plan can
be fleshed out before he can decide what
it is that they do next
valeri of Richards appears and so what
happens is she begins talking to dr.
doom now something to keep in mind here
is that when Valyria Richards was born
to Susan storm filaria Richards and
Susan were going through birth
complications and always actually dr.
doom that effectively saved her life
they made it possible for Valyria to be
born and so he's sort of an uncle to her
he's basically a very close member to
her but even more so than that and this
is why I love Hickman's writing so much
is because she looks at him not really
as a role model but as a person whose
intelligence is equal to if not
occasionally a little bit less than her
own and so because of that when it comes
to the mind he's an equal to her and so
she views him as maybe somebody she can
consult and that's what she's doing here
because of the fact that the future
Franklin Richards had appeared to
valaria and said all hope lies in doom
she's basically fulfilling this patch
she's finding out what it is or why it
is that all hope lies with now again she
doesn't know how the future is going to
turn out but her logic dictates that if
the future version of Franklin was going
to come to the past and tell her all
hope lies with doom then she better go
visit dr. Jamie and so what is up
happening here is that dr. doom of
course she explains what all had gone on
with her father with Reed Richards
creating a portal that allowed him to
access the Council of reeds and when dr.
doom asks what it is that she found when
she went through the portal but she
shows us that some of the reeds had been
killed that this council of reeds at
this temple had basically been in total
shambles and what she tells us is that
the Council of Reed's have effectively
been destroyed in their entirety or at
least they appear to have been destroyed
in their entirety but she also says and
this is actually a very very important
thing she also says that there are a
whole bunch of versions of dr. doom that
seemed to have been lobotomized and
they're just living below the the
facility itself the council chamber
itself and so when she travels into the
end of the building she actually
discovers that demand Celestials are
still there and the battle is still
raging on albeit with whatever few
forces happen to be left behind and so
while these verses of Reed are doing
what they can in the
again it's just not enough because we're
talking about entities from a different
reality that possess universal level
power that possess astronomical power
and so what is up happening here is well
as completely text list well we don't
really know everything that's going on
we know that valeri is trying to help
them that most likely she talked to them
but we're not given the full explanation
of what all had taken place and this is
actually interesting I'm not really sure
why a Jonathan Hickman chose to go this
route I wouldn't go as far as to say it
was a bad decision
it's just his the effect that he was
looking for was kind of lost on me when
I was going through this but what what
she tells dr. doom is that in the end
Reid made the wrong choice and this is
actually really interesting because had
valaria made the decision things would
have been vastly different and we
actually would have seen the future of
Franklin coming to fruition but what she
says here is that her father had the
choice between solving the problem of
humanity or else basically keeping his
family and because Reid chose to stay
with his family because he chose not to
take the same road that all the other
reads in the Council of reads chose
which was to basically abandon their
families that in the end he made their
own choice and he screwed up but more so
than that was funny with this is that
Valerius says that she notices something
is off about Doctor Doom now she does
not know about the fall of Hulk
storyline she does not know about those
events as far as I'm aware all she knows
is that by virtue of the fact that a
Doctor Doom is twitching a bit in one of
his hands because of the fact that he is
perspiring because of the fact that he's
showing characteristics that do not
exceed the normal kind of confidence
that he puts off complete control the
situation that something's not quite
right and valaria immediately deduces
that he has brain damage and so the the
agreement the two of them strike is that
she will find a way to cure dr. Doom's
brain damage if dr. doom agrees to
basically help Reed Richards whenever
the time comes when that help is needed
now we will actually find this out later
on following the death of Johnny Storm
and dr. doom is actually gonna join the
Future Foundation which creates it makes
some really cool storytelling it creates
a for some really cool dichotomy between
himself and the rest of the Fantastic
Four and the superheroes
so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's fantastic for what we
do now is we pick up with the death of
Johnny Storm now Johnny Storm dying was
a huge deal
it was a very big deal and the reason
why is because throughout the history of
the Fantastic Four the only person who
ever really died kind of was Ben Grimm
and that was why we saw the Fantastic
Four traveling to the realm of the one
above all and that's where we learned
that the one above all is effectively
Jack Kirby or at least some people say
is Jack Kirby you know honesty it could
be Jack Kirby or Stan Lee it's just
people psyched that because it was in
comics I can't really blame him for it
but the fact remains that with the death
of Johnny Storm this is actually pre
looted by an event called the war of the
four cities and if you guys recall our
discussions in the early videos on
Hickman's Fantastic Four we talked about
how the future version of Franklin
Richards had travelled into the past to
visit his younger self and wake up his
powers but he had also told a velarium
Richards that there was going to be a
war of the four cities now within this
story we pick up in part with the Future
Foundation now in the last video we
talked about how the Future Foundation
was a group formed by Reed Richards
using children and the reason why he
wanted to use children is because
they're not impacted by the world's
politics they don't make their decisions
based off religious motives they don't
care about political allegiances all
they care about is what their
imagination can let them achieve and so
they're effectively untainted by the
real world and so using children allows
Reed to basically do whatever he wants
to when it comes to the idea of trying
to solve the problem everything about
trying to make the world a better place
and so with this war of the four cities
we're actually gonna have to delve into
some history of Marvel Comics now a lot
of this is currently being covered in my
series a history of the Marvel Universe
but some of the stuff we're gonna talk
about we haven't gotten to yet now with
regards to the first of the four cities
this is old Atlantis now in Marvel
Comics way back in the day when the
earth was basically new when he was when
life was appearing for the very first
time the celestial showed up on earth
and they began experimenting on humans
on primitive man and they created the
deviance and they created the Eternals
and then they left
normal humans alone save for the fact
that the genes of normal humans were
modified so that at some future point in
time they would begin developing
superpowers for some people this was a
predisposition towards being bitten by a
radioactive spider and becoming
spider-man instead of dying for other
individuals it was the activation of a
gene that would grant them powers which
was the case of mutants but the fact
remains that with this period in time
those humans who were not enslaved by
the deviants after the Eternals had
basically bailed off began forming their
own cultures and their own civilizations
and the central hub so to speak of
civilization on earth at the time was
Atlantis it was a giant trading hub
technology was advanced far more than it
is right now in Marvel Comics which is
interesting and we'll explain why here
in a second but it was this massive
interweaving he was like the Roman
Empire before the Roman Empire and so
what ended up happening here is the
Celestials came back to basically see
how their work how their experiment was
progressing then the result was that the
deviants believed that the celestial was
wanting to take over the world and so
the deviants attacked the Celestials now
while this was happening the advance
citizens on Atlantis realized that this
conflict would likely lay waste to the
surface and so what they did is they
immersed of their city in domes of an
unknown composition in preparation for
the coming destruction and s exactly
what happened the war between the
deviants and the Celestials initiated
what's called the great Cataclysm
basically meaning that almost all
technology was wiped out and Atlantis
sank to the bottom of the ocean and so
once Atlantis dropped off you had
various themes and various groups that
were forming but within Atlantis you had
a sub sect of people that carried on the
tradition of the old ways they never let
go of the past this continued on until
the modern day and this is part of the
war of the four cities these people who
hold on to past traditions who don't
really follow the ideologies of Maine
where the sub-mariner have come to the
conclusion that is high time that
Atlantis take over the surface they
basically return back to the surface
world and begin conquering all over
again and so what's going to happen here
is that they are going to find
themselves in a conflict with what are
called the universal Inhumans now after
the Celestials had showed up on earth
meddled with the genes of humanity the
Cree race on the far side of the
universe had realized what was going on
of course they had been fighting the
scrolls for quite some time but because
the war took place across the universe
you had different battle stations you
had different territories that operated
as military campaign points and things
like that and the earth was in a very
strategic location it was basically in a
place to where if it were conquered they
could easily sway the tide of battle and
so what ended up happening here is the
Kree saw the Celestials meddling with
the genes of humanity creating the
deviants and the Eternals and so what
they did is they took a sub sect of
humans and they modified their genes so
that when these humans were exposed to
the Terrigen mists they would undergo a
transformation into any number of races
who in turn would go into those
particular races start civil wars and
allow the Kree to to basically take over
that planet and then continue their
expansion of their own empire now
somewhere along the line the leader of
the Kree race the supreme intelligence
realized that if this happened long
enough eventually it would lead to the
crease own destruction and so what ended
up happening is the supreme intelligence
ordered that all of these inhuman
projects be completely eliminated and
all of them were except for five you had
the chameleons you had the Badoon and
you had a handful of others of course
you had the Inhumans on the planet Earth
and so this represents the second of the
four cities and what happened is that
these universal Inhumans the races that
exist way out on the eat on different
parts of the universe have decided that
it's time to take over the planet Earth
now with regards to the third city this
is what's called the forever City on the
planet Earth there is a guy named
Herbert Wyndham but most likely you've
heard him referred to as the High
Evolutionary and he was a guy from the
1930s who was obsessed with genetics he
was actually a really big deal he was
really involved with the studies of mr.
sinister and will actually get to a
discussion in my videos on a history of
the Marvel Universe with regards to mr.
sinister because he was responsible for
a lot of different things he was
responsible for Cyclops the meddling of
his powers when he was younger he was
responsible for the creation of the
weapons Plus project which led to
Captain America
it led to Wolverine it led to Deadpool
mr. sinister was behind the motivation
and why it is that we know that if
Cyclops and Jean Grey ever had a child
it'd be wildly powerful mr. sinister is
behind a lot of things that have taken
place in the realm of science and Marvel
Comics as a whole but because Herbert
Wyndham because the High Evolutionary
was so obsessed with genes what ended up
doing was basically performing
experiments on himself the problem with
this was he was considered crazy by his
contemporaries by various scientists in
the 1930s at the time and so he was
effectively out stood from the
scientific community and so he took up
residence in a place called wonder core
mountain and what he did is he began
basically modifying the genes of animals
in order to hyper I guess the to speed
up their evolution to basically make
them human-like so to speak and the fact
that they could talk in terms of the
fact that they were bipedal so on and so
forth he had his group called the new
man well while all this was happening he
also had the intention of taking over
the world and so what he did is he went
underground and he created a place
called the forever city and the forever
city was basically a location whereby he
had an evolution machine it would allow
him to basically speed up the evolution
of all beings on the planet Earth all of
whom would swear allegiance to him
because he would present himself as
their leader the problem with this was
that when he activated the machine he
considered it a failure because of the
fact that the Machine actually forced
those who were exposed to it to revert
in evolution meaning they would go
backwards in evolution they wouldn't go
forward and so he effectively abandoned
the forever city and so his time
progressed and various underground
creatures like the Malloys and so on and
so forth discovered this forever city
they began calling it the lost city of
the High Evolutionary this represents
the third city in the war of the four
cities and the reason why is because
those who are currently occupying this
territory have decided that it's now
their time to take over the surface
world now the final city in this
discussion and the one that actually
leads directly into the death of Johnny
storm is the negative zone and the
forces of Annihilus now what this does
is this actually picks up after an event
called annihilation now for those of you
guys who never read annihilation it was
a really really good story and it
actually coincided with the events of
civil war and it was really interesting
the way these two stories compared again
with one another then the reason why is
because the the connection between the
two was Richard Ryder of the Nova Corps
and what had happened is that while
Captain America and Iron Man were
feuding on the planet Earth in the
negative zone Annihilus had basically
discovered the negative zones equivalent
of the power cosmic the power that
Galactus wields and so because Annihilus
is obsessed with killing everybody in
order to ensure that he can't die that
no one can conquer him
Annihilus took over the negative zone
and then invaded the main 6160 universe
and began unleashing a horde of of its
forces it was called the annihilation
wave and it basically spread like a
plague throughout the universe
conquering planets killing everything
that it came across it was one of the
most impressive displays of death and
destruction in the history of Marvel
Comics now we're this led of course of
the capture of Galactus and different
things like that going on and there were
a lot of teams that were taking place
and even led into the formation of the
guardians of the galaxy under a
star-lord what ended up happening here
is once
Annihilus was defeated he was basically
convent to find back to actually a
negative zone he was basically stuck
there and so what ended up happening
here is the Fantastic Four the future
foundation and these various forces were
going about their own normal business
but within the Marvel Universe you had
what I think was called the court of the
negative zone or the court of Annihilus
or something along those lines but it
was basically the remnants of the
annihilation wave who had taken up
residence on earth and we're operating
to ensure a nihilist could actually come
back and succeed and wiping out all life
in the earth-616 universe and so when
did up happening is that because Reed
Richards was the first person to
discover the negative zone because he's
consistently had a portal that accesses
the negative zone the court had
basically surrounded the Baxter building
by virtue of jobs and businesses and so
on and so forth and then invaded the
Baxter building and opened up the portal
and so for the first time in Hickman's
run of the Fantastic Four Franklin
Richards lets everyone know that his
powers have returned when he wipes out
the forces of of the annihilation wave
over the the preemptive forces but what
happens is that the
Future Foundation Franklin Richards and
and Johnny Storm and those guys go into
the negative zone
for the purpose of destroying Annihilus
forces to ensure that he can never
invade the earth 6-1-6 universe again
and so what happens here is that while
they're doing the best they can
ultimately they're overwhelmed because
Annihilus has billions of soldiers
billions with a beat he's got so many
soldiers is unbelievable and so what is
up happening as a future foundation
basically bails out but someone has to
stay behind and they have to basically
lock the door and then randomize the
access code so that no one can figure
out how to gain access again no one can
get in and no one can get out and so
what is up happening here is Johnny
Storm stays behind and this to me is one
of the best moments and in Hickman's run
because Johnny Storm is not he's not
scared he's not afraid he doesn't care
he's he's angry and he's confident
because he turns around he says a
billion to one and then he just says
flame on and in depth and then it
immediately cuts to the end of the comic
now when this happened when he Hickman
revealed that Johnny Storm was basically
dead it took the comic book world by
storm there's no better way to say that
it it sent shockwaves know there had
never been an instance when Johnny Storm
had died because the Fantastic Four just
don't die it doesn't happen sometimes
the x-men die sometimes Captain America
gives up there's been a couple times
where Captain America supposedly died
we'd turned out he was alive you know
Thor died and Thor disassembled during
the events of Ragnarok but the members
of the Fantastic Four don't die that's
off-limits you don't kill them and so it
was a huge surprise to see Johnny Storm
killed off now that being said with
Johnny storm of being dead with
Fantastic Four issue number 588 Hickman
gave us a comic that had no words
it was literally all just images but I
will tell you guys right now this is one
of the best comics that you're ever
gonna see and the reason why is because
it literally just gives us stages we
don't have to read what's happening to
know what's going on and what's really
interesting about this is that because
Ben Grimm was the one that had to
basically watch Johnny Storm die that
had to watch Johnny Storm sacrifice his
life this impacts Ben Grimm more than
anything else
then what this does is it initially
picks up with a call to arms I mean the
Avengers basically everyone shows up
everyone's like oh my god Johnny Storm
is dead because in the realm of Marvel
Comics the Fantastic Four are basically
royalty guys it's like watching a prince
you know or a king or queen die you know
it is it's an insane thing to see and so
the superhero community whether they're
villains or otherwise are in total shock
and so of course you have Thor you have
Wolverine you have the New Avengers more
or less Captain America Iron Man they
show up and they visit the the Future
Foundation they visit the the Fantastic
Four and the response from Ben Grimm is
he doesn't know what to do you know he's
just kind of lost here because despite
the banter that he and Johnny Storm had
the fact that they would bicker all the
time once you got past you know what
seemed to be bitterness between the two
all you found was love you know Ben
Grimm and Johnny Storm had a strong
connection with one another because they
were effectively the best of friends and
we knew that because when it came down
to it when it came down to the Fantastic
Four fighting together Ben Grimm had
Johnny's back and Johnny had been
Grimm's back but now in the eyes of Ben
Grimm no one's got his corner you know
no one is is behind him and so what
happens is that when Susan storm returns
from her mission she's told that Johnny
Storm is dead and again the the shock on
her face is absolute absolute shock and
absolute you know a crushing sensation
because once we get into day three we
learn that with her brother being dead
she spent almost the entire time
isolated she's been away from everybody
she will not let Reed Richards touch her
she will not let anybody have anything
to do with her and so on day four who
Reed Richards supposed to his weapons
facility in the Baxter building and
grabs the ultimate nullifier now for
those of you guys who don't know the
ultimate nullifier is a big deal this
thing is capable of just wiping out
anything now you know what it destroys
its relative to the to the drive to the
ambition and the intelligence of the
person who wields it but because Reed
Richards is in such an emotional state
and because he's so angry and because
he's so intelligent he could simply
press the button and wipe out the
universe if he wanted to and that's what
he does he goes to the portal of the
negative zone he effectively you know
accesses it is you not able to cross
through into the poor
but he can see into the inside and he
sees Annihilus and he basically
threatens him with the ultimate
nullifier and Annihilus just presents
him with a shirt of Johnny Storm and
that's all it takes that's that's all it
takes and so Reed Richards just kind of
walks away and so what we do is we move
to day five which is effectively the
funeral for Johnny Storm we see everyone
here every almost every single superhero
that's ever been important in the lives
of the Fantastic Four are present here
and so as these individuals are talking
to one another as they're speaking with
one another Ben Grimm gets angry now
this I think is one of the best absolute
best moments of the story because with
with the the stages of grief
you know the stages of dealing with
someone who dies anger is one of the
most prominent and one of the most
dangerous stages depending on you know
how close you were to the loved one that
you lost and so what ends up happening
here is of course Doctor Doom actually
vacates Latveria for a time he put some
Christophe Renard in charge
and he actually leaves and goes to pay
his respects to the Fantastic Four but
we also see spider-man spending time
with with Franklin Richards now this
will be important because was actually
gonna happen this is going to be a story
where spider-man works with Franklin on
how to deal with the fact that Johnny
Storm died and this again is a really
good story if you asked Sal if you if
you or you you tweet Khali pop and you
ask him what do you think about
spider-man's you know conversation with
Franklin Richards after the death of
Johnny Storm he'll tell you it's one of
the best stories that he's ever read in
the history of Marvel Comics and so we
switch over to Valerie Richards and the
Future Foundation and what's interesting
and what I hope you guys notice about
this is everyone's dealing with the
situation in their own way
initially the Future Foundation have
their own their own ideas the thought is
maybe we replace you know replace Johnny
Storm with someone else with she-hulk
storm Black Panther Wyatt Wingfoot who
has long since been an ally to the to
the Fantastic Four and a close personal
friend of Johnny Storm but she erases
all that issue says the only thing they
need to do before they do anything else
is kill Annihilus and so what we do here
and this this I said this is why I think
this is one of the one of the best
moments of the entirety of the story is
we pick up with Ben Grimm and what
happens is that on day 26 Ben gray
meets with with Bruce Banner and with
Donald Blake the human form of Thor and
of course we see that the Donald Blake
has a sticker his cane which if he hits
on the ground it will turn into the the
hammer of Mjolnir and he'll become Thor
and so what happens is they present him
with a I guess with an image of Johnny
Storm and initially Ben Grimm doesn't
want to have anything to do with it and
so Donald Blake transforms into Thor and
he and Ben Grimm begin fighting one
another and then Bruce Banner changed
into the Incredible Hulk and they start
fighting all three are getting into a
conflict and they're battling and
initially this seems as though they're
picking a fight but what they're doing
here is they're letting Ben Grimm work
out his anger they're letting him work
through his hatred and his rage because
Ben Grimm is so strong if he were to
freak out and if you were to just start
attacking anything he would almost lay
waste to the planet but both Thor and
The Incredible Hulk are two of the only
people in existence who can withstand a
beating from Ben Grimm almost completely
unfazed and so this is why I say this is
such a great story or such a great
aspect of the story because this is
basically just Ben Grimm coping with the
death of his best friend and so what we
do as we begin to wrap this up as we can
begin to bring this to an end is we join
Reed Richards on day 29 and this is
Hickman kind of bringing us back to
reality
it's the segment bringing us back to the
story saying okay you know you guys have
had your time to focus on the death of
Johnny Storm we have to get back to the
bigger picture here we have to get back
to this great big huge story arc that
he's giving us and so while Reed
Richards is going over his list of
things the idea that the in the
negatives oh maybe invading the planet
Earth the idea that the universal
Inhumans want to conquer the planet
Earth Franklin Richards power set these
are all these are all important things
that are you know a major threat to them
you know Galactus possibly trying to
consume earth as a big deal and for
those of you guys who don't know this
harkens back to the original appearance
of Galactus in Marvel Comics when he
first met the Fantastic Four the fact
that Galactus was forced out on bad
terms was a admit the possibility
existed that Galactus could come back at
any point in time and consume the earth
and there would be virtually nothing the
superheroes
could really do to stop him but more so
than that Reed Richards says that the
reformation of the Council of reeds
is necessary and this is something that
I'd love for you guys to keep in the
back of your head because this will be
very important later on down the line
but as this begins to come to a close
what happens is Reed Richards is met
with the arrival of his father
Nathaniel Richards so as we continue our
discussion on Johnathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four we pick up now with what
I consider to be one of the absolute
best moments of the story this sits
right up there with the ending of
Hickman's Fantastic Four the
conversation between you know Galactus
and Franklin Richards about how they'll
both stand until the end of time this is
this is right up there this is the
segment of the story that deals with a
conversation between spider-man and
Franklin Richards and what happens here
is during this month of mourning
basically this 38:32 31-day period
whereby all the members of the Fantastic
Four and even some of the other
superheroes in the Marvel Universe are
dealing with the death of Johnny Storm
spider-man
visits Franklin on a rooftop and
Franklin is kind of here just trying to
understand everything that's going on
and what happens is he basically just
starts relating to spider-man as a child
and this is why this is so good
because when you cast aside all the
powers that Franklin Richards has when
you cast aside the fact that he can just
make the universe whatever he wants it
to be the one thing he has to contend
with when it comes to his powers is he
cannot bring Johnny Storm back he cannot
resurrect Johnny storms than dead and a
lot of people will look at this and ask
why if he could resurrect Galactus why
could he not resurrect Johnny Storm
because Galactus is a cosmic construct
he is and he's an aspect of the universe
it would be like Franklin Richards you
know recreating a planet after that
planet was destroyed it's easy to do
because it's just a cosmic as part of
the cosmos is just the way things are
with Galactus he's just an amalgamation
of cosmic energies and so to simply
reconstitute those energies in a way
that take on the form of Galactus with
all the same memories and all the same
views and experiences and so on is not
difficult but to recreate a human being
who has a soul and whose soul has
presumably passed on to the realm of the
dead Franklin cannot access
that area and so he's effectively trying
to open a door or trying to get into a
room through a door that he can't open
and so this is why it's so hard for him
to deal with the fact that Johnny Storm
has died but more so than that what's
really interesting about all this is
that spider-man tells Franklin the best
thing to do is to just clear their heads
is to get away from spending so much
time being down about the situation and
to do basically just sort of take a day
for themselves and so that's what they
do they end up going out and they get a
hot dog with one another and this is why
I love Hickman's run of the Fantastic
Four so much because he does a great job
of humanizing the characters when we
look at characters in Marvel Comics we
look at Captain America we look at you
know daredevil Iron Man so on and so
forth for the most part there's this
wall that exists between us and them we
recognize they're fictional characters
they say whatever the writers want them
to say they do whatever the writers want
them to do but when you're going through
Hickman's run of the Fantastic Four it
it doesn't feel that way and maybe I'm
reading a little more into it than I
probably should but it doesn't feel like
fictional characters to me it doesn't
feel like nonsense they feel like
genuine people with their own organic
thoughts and desires and someone and so
forth and so what happens here is that
as short of this is while the two of
them are talking a Peter Parker reveals
to Franklin that his uncle had died when
he was younger and what this does is it
creates a very close relationship
between the two of them because they're
both coming from the same place you know
Franklin Richards lost his uncle Johnny
Storm Peter Parker lost Uncle Ben and
because both of these individuals played
such prominent roles in their lives they
have effectively it kind of bridges the
gap between the two of them now there
are some differences here and hickman
doesn't shy away from these differences
he doesn't move away and try to ignore
them he actually embraces them here with
Uncle Ben the value of Uncle Ben in the
life of Peter Parker was not recognized
until he was gone it was the perfect
example of you don't know what you have
until it's gone and Peter Parker talks
about this he says that he didn't really
realize how close or how much he needed
Uncle Ben until Uncle Ben was gone with
Franklin it's similar but it's not the
same a Johnny Storm played a very active
role in the life of Franklin and he was
around for quite some time of course you
know Johnny Storm was an active member
of the Fantastic Four went on a series
of adventures but more so than that he
and Franklin shared a very close
relationship more so than spider-man and
uncle
and Spiderman looked at Uncle ban as a
father figure whereas Franklin looked at
Johnny stolen for all intents and
purposes as a brotherly kind of figure
really more of an extremely close friend
than an actual relative and so what is
it happening here is that at the two of
them begin to go on and this is this is
why I love this story so much Franklin
says that he has a secret to tell Peter
Parker and when Peter asks him what it
is Franklin says he thinks he could have
saved Johnny Storm and this is so
awesome because this is this really hits
of the heart of Franklin's struggling it
hits at the heart of him as a character
with all his vast abilities he couldn't
he doesn't feel like he could have saved
where he feels like he could have but he
didn't and this is why he struggles so
much because partic'lar could have
easily saved him Franklin could have
simply use his powers wiped away the
entirety of the annihilation forces in
saved Johnny Storm but Franklin didn't
and he didn't because he's a child
despite all the things that he's done in
the past all the crazy situations that
have happened around him
they happened because he was able to
think we're headed but in the situation
that they were in when the annihilation
wave was threatening to invade earth
Franklin got caught up in the situation
he panicked and he didn't quite know
what to do and so the result is that
when he tells spider-man that he thinks
he could have saved you know Johnny
Storm
spider-man replies by saying that he
knows he could have saved his Uncle Ben
and this is so important for the realm
of spider-man because it tells us that
every single day day in and day out when
he wakes up in the morning when he hangs
out with his friends when he's fighting
crime when he is going to bed Peter
Parker sits down and realizes he could
have saved the life of Uncle Ben but
then the question becomes what if he had
what would spider-man be like if Uncle
Ben had lived now there is an actual
story in Marvel Comics that spirited
that that deals with that and it'd be
kind of a cool story to run over one day
but for right now for our discussion
this basically goes towards the
statement that Peter Parker makes to
Franklin in saying that the decisions
that they make the people that they meet
over the course of their life both good
and bad experiences shape them on a
fundamental level and what he says here
is something I'd like you to pay
extremely close attention to because
this will be a huge factor and why it is
the Franklin Richards in the future who
was doing the things that he did what
spider-man says here is that because
Uncle Ben died he gained a valuable
understanding of what it meant to do the
right thing at the right time to not be
guided by anger to
not be guided by rage to accept the fact
that people make mistakes that he's done
things that he wished he didn't do and
there are things that he didn't do that
he wished he had and the result is that
he has to live with that but it's made
him a better person much in the same
vein Franklin Richards dwells on the
idea that he believes he could have
saved Johnny Storm and he most likely
could have but the fact that he didn't
does not mean the Franklin is a failure
and this is what Peters telling him but
he's not a failure as a human being he
simply just he was in a situation he was
caught up and he didn't quite know what
to do and so the result is that this as
this little segment of the story begins
to begins to wrap up what is up
happening as Peter just sort of brings
things to a close and takes Franklin
Richards back home and what this does is
this leads us into the official launch
of the Future Foundation story and Peter
Parker becoming part of the Future
Foundation now for those of you guys who
have seen various images of Peter Parker
during your travels where you've seen
him in his white suit basically dressed
in this weird-looking white suit this is
future foundation this is Jonathan
Hickman's run of the Fantastic Four and
what we do here is we transition to two
Reed Richards after this morning phase
is basically over and what happens is
he's watching a an image of August a
hologram a message from Johnny Storm
basically telling them you know yes it
sucks that I'm dead yes it sucks that
I'm not in your life anymore but you
guys got to move on
you guys got to look to the future you
can't dwell on the past and so for Reed
while he's watched this video time and
time again it's helped him to sort of
move forward it's helped him to accept
the fact that Johnny Storm loved them
that Johnny Storm sacrificed his life to
protect them and so in the end the only
thing they can really do is continue to
move forward and so what we do here is
we pick up with spider-man officially
joining or I guess heading over to the
Baxter building to meet with Susan storm
and this is interesting because this is
when the costumes of the Fantastic Four
begin to change and on its surface
Hickman doesn't immediately tell us
what's going on but even when he does
tell us didn't spend a whole lot of time
doing it there's not so huge grandiose
explanation it's not a storyline in and
of itself is basically Susan storm
telling Peter Parker that after the
death of Johnny storm that things needed
to change it didn't make any sense to
wear costumes that had fours on them
anymore because there weren't four of
them anymore instead there were only
three because Johnny Storm
and so in order to both respect to the
memory of Johnny Storm but also move
into the future
they brought Peter Parker in to
basically not necessarily take the place
of Johnny storm but to be a temporary
substitute now the reason why this
matters is because Peter Parker and
Johnny Storm have a friendship that goes
back a long time in fact the first real
friend said that they had evolved out of
the amazing spider-man issue number one
when Peter Parker tried to join the
Fantastic Four and they turned him down
but because of the fact that he spent
time with them because of the various
crossovers where he fought alongside of
them a friendship began to bloom between
the two of them and so while I wouldn't
go as far as to say that they were like
brothers I will go as far as to say that
for the Fantastic Four it only made
sense to have spider-man come in and
step into this role and this is really
cool because the the outfit that he gets
it's very similar in terms of what is
capable of to the iron spider armor now
if those you guys who don't know the
iron spider armor is actually very
anticipated in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a lot of people believe that
costume is going to show up but the iron
spider armor was a suit given to
spider-man by Tony Stark when Spiderman
was fighting on Tony Stark's side during
the Civil War event and the iron spider
costume allowed him to basically change
his physical appearance he actually took
on the the black costume from Secret
Wars and during the the whole I guess
prelude to the venom saga you know was
just kind of a quick little scene just
give us a sort of idea what the suit was
capable of but because of the fact that
the Fantastic Four's outfits have been
consistently composed of unstable
molecules that unstable molecule a
formula basically allowed Susan storm to
use her powers while she was on the suit
it allowed Reed Richards to stretch the
suit and so on and so forth but it also
benefits in the sense that that Spider
Man can sort of modify the suit to I
guess suit his own situation to sort of
make it his own and so what happens here
is that as they're going about as
they're having their own conversations
and they're sort of conversing with one
another what we end up doing is we
actually jump to Pavlov which is a
prison and that is where the wizard is
being held now the wizard originally
appeared in the beginning of our
discussion on Hickman's Fantastic Four
and we didn't really have a whole lot to
say about him suffice it to say that he
presented the catalyst for Reed Richards
recognizing that people are just bad and
they're gonna do bad things and the only
way to to basically save the world was
to solve the problem of everything which
initiated the whole Council of reeds
storyline but with this group called
advanced idea mechanics
sort of these enigmatic individuals who
are bent on world domination through
technological means they had been
brought in for the purpose of rescuing
the wizard now we're not originally
given an idea we're not initially told
why it is that this is happening instead
we see that Thea
the Fantastic Four alongside Spider Man
show up in their new get ups with the
new pain suits on the on the vessels and
with their new costumes and they
basically go through and defeat advanced
idea mechanics and they eventually get
into a skirmish with the wizard all of
the wizard is successfully able to
escape now what he says is that Reed
Richards has something that belongs to
him and he's gonna take it back now what
the wizard is referring to is his son
quote-unquote the wizard didn't really
have biological children per se instead
he was a genius-level inventor who went
through and created people he created
human beings of all shapes and sizes and
then used them as an army to carry out
his various schemes but the child that
he had created had been taken by Reed
Richards when the wizard was originally
imprisoned and that child is part of the
future foundation more or less being
taught the various ideas of technology
and how to make the world a better place
which goes directly in line with the
Wizards idea of dominating the world and
taking away humanity's freewill owing to
the belief that humanity would use its
freedom to make its own decisions as it
means to destroy itself and so what is
up happening here is that once the
wizard and the the various groups get
away we sort of see some some banter
back and forth but we actually end up
jumping back to the Baxter building now
this is a really cool moment in the
story what happens here over the course
of the next little while and the reason
why is because at the end of the last
video we had talked about how Reed
Richards father Nathanael Richards had
come back and this was a very big deal
because Nathaniel Richards had appeared
off and on throughout the history of
Marvel Comics but he had never had a I
guess a long term role in his son's life
he basically bailed out on Reed Richards
when he was a child and then hadn't seen
him for decades now of course we
actually found out that it was because
Nathaniel Richards in I guess in
relation to Reed he was one of a
multitude of Nathaniel Richards from
across the multiverse that were pulled
into this conflict and they all started
hunting each other down
and so Nathaniel was basically jumping
from one reality to the next in order to
keep himself alive he was literally just
on the run trying to keep himself from
dying and so picking back up with the
with the Baxter building
it's the small things I think that
really build Hickman's run into
something special and the reason why I
say this is that with Peter Parker
sitting down and getting ready to
partake in the roast
being that's been cooked by a Nathaniel
Richards he initially goes to sit down
and Johnny Storm spot and Franklin says
no you can't sit there
that's Johnny spot you know that is that
is Johnny's place and it's sort of just
paying respects you know even though
Johnny's not there it's just kind of
paying a respect and saying we have to
keep Johnny's memory alive now of course
this is designed to be a temporary thing
and as we'll find later on these events
with Johnny Storm aren't necessarily
what they what they appear to be but the
fact remains that one of the funny
little bits here is that while they're
all sitting down for dinner they
actually say grace now the reason why I
like this is that while it's not really
important and has virtually no bearing
on the story whatsoever it's funny to
hear of Franklin Richards say grace
because when you're a god and you can
make your thoughts a reality of what
relevance are God's to you or what
relevance are you know other beings to
you Franklin Richards could easily
destroy the sky fathers Franklin
Richards is on par with the Celestials
Franklin Richards is as powerful as some
of the most powerful beings in Marvel
Comics the only ones that really surpass
him are like eternity and infinity and
even they might find themselves with a
bit of a challenge when it comes to
trying to take him head-on if his powers
were to fully manifest and and reach the
entirety of what it is that they were
capable of but again this is just a
little bit of a funny situation here
nothing too big just you know something
that that I thought you guys might might
enjoy a little bit but what also happens
is we get a little bit of the of the
look of the Fantastic Four
beyond the conflicts and again this is
why Hickman so cool because he gives us
you know the stuff between the pages so
to speak then of course when Reed is
talking about everything that's
currently going on about the universal
and humans and so on and so forth the
initial idea is what maybe they should
terraform the moon and that way they can
give the Inhumans a place to live as
opposed to those individuals having to
having to live on earth and where
everybody else on at the tables says
yeah sure that's fine that's a great
idea
Nathaniel says that's stupid and this is
really funny because Reed Richards has
basically been in an environment for so
long where everybody just agrees with
him that it's refreshing to have
somebody say Reed that's a stupid idea
now this doesn't mean that Nathaniel's
being a dick it simply means that
everybody in the Fantastic Four is so
used to how intelligent Reed is very
rarely what he's saying we should do
something without having thought about
it first but even for Reed Richards it's
nice to have someone come along and say
you should not do that
is that silly but at the same time it's
just a dad relating to his son you know
and for Reedus is good to have that
feeling because it's one that he has not
felt for quite some time and so as
things begin it progresses as dinner
begins to pass what is up happening is
we see that the you know the kids are
put to bed and so on and so forth
and Nathaniel Richards and valaria
Richards meet with Reed for a
conversation now for those of you guys
who did not see my last video we had
talked about how valaria had traveled to
Latveria to visit dr. doom and she had
made a pact with dr. doom that if doom
would assist in defeating Reed Richards
that she would help dr. doom fix
whatever brain problem it is that he's
suffering from now the reason why he was
suffering from a brain issue went into a
story that was previously existing we
don't really need to go into that you're
welcome to watch the video if you if you
want to see it it seems like an
unnecessary thing to add at this point
into into our discussion but the fact
remains here that Reed is not happy with
this REE does not like the idea of
associating with dr. doom because
they've been enemies for so long but
also because dr. doom is a very
nefarious person dr. doom isn't
necessarily someone who had tricked
people he's a very honorable guy which
will actually find out here in a little
while but the fact remains that he's
basically just a dick and Reed doesn't
want to have anything to do with that
but the fact remains that because of
Valyria thinks it is a good idea because
Nathaniel's saying hey I've been in the
future this is something that needs to
happen in the end Reed Richards more or
less it goes along with it and so ones
up happening is of course we see them
pick up with dr. doom now dr. doom in
the Fantastic Four or in the Baxter
building is one of the greatest moments
in Hickman's run and the reason why is
because all he does is just give Ben
Graham a hard time and this this is this
is such a great this is such a great
moment you guys are gonna get one hell
of a kick out of this
so of course bin Grimm's reaction to
finding out that dr. doom is in the
Baxter building is exactly what you
expect it to be you know Ben Grimm just
freaks he's like no way we're know
that's ridiculous
doom does not need to be here he's our
arch-nemesis you know what's going on
here and of course Reed says no it's
fine I allowed him to be here you know
and then doom starts haunting Ben Graham
and of course with Johnny storms death
fresh and the minds of everyone dr. doom
being dr. doom decides to use that
subject and what he does is he asked Ben
Grimm he says is it true that while
Johnny Storm was facing off against over
a veritable horde of the annihilation
wave that Ben Grimm surrounded by
children ran off in head and that just
sends Ben Grimm right over the edge and
he loses his mind now this is kind of
important because if Ben Grimm were to
get his hands on dr. doom he would
probably kill him in this this stage of
complete rage but because Susan storm
steps and she sort of stops everything
she's sure does sort of just basically
stops the two of them where they're at
using her ability to cast force fields
and the initial idea here is that no one
really understands why Ben Grimm is here
aside from read and valaria and
Nathanael and of course doom himself no
one knows why he is allowed to be inside
the Bakshi building but the fact remains
that Ben Grimm doesn't like what's going
on and so the result is of course he
takes a dragon man and they end up
leaving out dragon man we don't need to
worry about its you guys are walking
look him up he's not really intricate
for our discussion here but he just
kinda like a mascot so to speak for the
Fantastic Four and they end up bailing
out now initially Reed is you know says
Susan you should go spend time with them
figure out what's going on you know try
to get things sorted out and her
response is that Reed is an idiot for
having dr. doom here she doesn't know
why he's here and she's not happy about
it but the funny thing is that dooms
response is that in the end his goal is
to fix whatever problem it is with his
brain and it doesn't matter to him what
else is going on especially the thoughts
and feelings of Susan storm and again
this is another perfect example of
Hickman writing Susan storms not putting
up with any of dr. doom [ __ ] and what
she says is that if he keeps mouthing
off she's gonna send some air bubbles
into his brain and reduce him to the
intelligence level of a vegetable and
and of course doom shuts up which of
course I would probably do the same but
the result is that you know spider-man
makes a couple jokes here and there
nothing to at nothing too major but we
end up transitioning to the the room so
to speak what they call it which is more
or less kind of like the the auditorium
the meeting hall where the Future
Foundation to gather together for their
lessons under the direction of Reed
Richards in order to solve various
problems and so of course a Peter Parker
being inducted into the Future
Foundation the other members know who he
is as a superhero but they're not really
acquainted with his intelligence and so
as soon as Peter Parker shows up he
immediately makes an impact by asking
some various serious questions are the
injuries of Doctor Doom in terms of his
brain are they physical injuries that is
they are portions of his brain missing
is a simply psychological does he
believe he's not able to access those
portions of his brain or is it entirely
possible that those portions of his
brain you know not necessarily physical
are some we just gone that he just can't
access those for whatever reason they've
been wiped from his mind in their
entirety and so while the rest of the
future foundation is a little shocked at
his intelligence valaria Richards chimes
in and says that if the the case is that
his brain is structurally intact that is
to say the physical structure of his
brain has not been changed then it's a
very simple concept of dr. Doom's brain
basically just needs a reboot that if
there's a backup of all of his memories
and his intelligence they can grab that
backup and they can use it and this is a
really funny moment here because Valyria
is of course she's talking to dr. doom
while Reid's listening on and she says
we need a backup and then doom just kind
of like yes so backup you know I mean
he's just kind of thinking for a second
and it seems like he doesn't really
grasp what it is is going on and they
just kind of you know look at one
another for a second and doom a soul
area if she's trying to annoy him and
she just sits there for a second or two
and then she says I said we need a
backup and then doom finally figures out
what is she's talking about this isn't
really huge but I love this kind of
thing I love this kind of thing in
comics because it again it makes them
human it you know this is the kind of
thing that you would see and you would
laugh at if you saw it happen in real
life and and so to me it was just a
really a really great moment but what we
do here is we pick up in in Latveria
proper now once we're in Latveria now
what we find out is that this entire
situation is actually going to rely on
the character of Christoph Bernard now
initially when I was going through this
and I'd actually forgotten some of the
writing that Hickman had done here I was
trying to figure out a way to to add
christophe Renard into our explanation
were the great things that we don't have
to because Jonathan Hickman basically
gives us that he essentially gives us
the rundown of you know who Christoph
Renard is and what we're told is that at
some point in the history of Latveria
there was a rebellion that was
orchestrated and while dr. doom was able
to quell the rebellion Christoph Renard
was a child who was orphaned by the
death of his parents and so what ended
up happening is dr. doom took Christoph
Renard as his own but did this for a
couple reasons one because dr. doom
probably felt bad for him although
within Marvel Comics assuming anybody's
actually writing dr. Doo
he should be written he would never
admit to that but the other half was
that dr. doom wanted to back up he
wanted to make sure that if something
happened to him if he died that his
legacy would be carried on through an
heir and so what he did is he took all
of his memories all of his intelligence
all the knowledge that he had on the
dark arts on science on technology and
put it into the mind of Christoph Renard
now well this does make Christoph Renard
intelligent the best way to think about
this is if his brain was a computer then
the all the stuff of Doctor Doom
everything that makes up who Doctor Doom
is it's like a file sitting on that
computer somewhere it's just waiting to
be retrieved so that it can be used in a
situation and just like this and so what
happens is that after activating a piece
of machinery the mind of Doctor Doom is
basically restored back to its normal
self
now of course Reed Richards up to this
point was not aware of the fact that a
patch was struck between valaria and
Doctor Doom he simply thought that they
were going to help fix Doctor Doom
because it's just the right thing to do
because Reed is not a terrible human
being
but once Reed is filled in on the
situation and once he's told that the
entire basis behind this was to I was at
the behest of a packed what we find out
is that healing dr. doom fixing dr. doom
was done for the purpose of a having dr.
doom defeat Reed Richards now what we'll
learn later on is he's not actually
going to be facing off against this Reed
he's gonna be facing off against the
Council of reeds which is gonna make for
one hell of a story so as you guys can
probably tell from the length of the
video this is a big one and the reason
why is of course we missed a video for
the last couple days that's because I've
been trying to find a way to basically
bring this whole segment of Hickman's
Fantastic Four into order and the reason
why is because if you guys watch my last
video I had basically told you that from
that point going forward things were
gonna explode it was gonna get
absolutely crazy and Hickman was gonna
start grabbing these different ties and
he was gonna start bringing them all
together and so for those of you guys
who were kind of curious about where the
whole plot thread of the war of the four
cities was going to this is where we
find out we find out this is basically
where things are sort of wrapping up now
again for those of you guys who didn't
see that video the war of the four
cities was a premonition given to
Larry Richards the genius daughter of
Reed Richards by the future version of
Franklin Richards and what Franklin said
is that there will be a war of the four
cities and we didn't know exactly what
it was that he was referring to at the
time Hickman hadn't really unveiled
everything but as the story's progressed
so far over the course of our
discussions what we know is that there
are a there are groups of Inhumans that
exist beyond the earth and of course the
Inhumans were experiments by the Kree
for the purpose of exposing different
races to the Terrigen mists who in turn
would morph into various races in and of
themselves they might have powers they
might not they all serve different kinds
of purposes but the goal was to
basically use the Inhumans as a way to
infiltrate different races across the
cosmos allowing the Kree to take over
those races and expand their own their
own Empire that was the premise behind
the Inhumans on earth what we learned
was that our earth Inhumans were not the
only one so there were other Inhumans
from across the cosmos from across the
universe who had received this same
treatment and they were considered to be
the universal Inhumans and its harm had
come when they had basically made the
argument that it was time for them to
take over the earth to make earth their
their rightful place now as far as I'm
aware Hickman doesn't really give us a
reason why except to say it's just part
of the story and we could just kind of
take it you know for what it is we don't
really need to read too much into that
but the second of these groups was of
course the the members of the forever
City which was a which was a city
basically created by the High
Evolutionary a man who lived his life
according to the premise of evolving
himself and others as best he could and
so the result was that he created
something called the ascension engine
which basically jump-started the
evolution of various people who stepped
into that city whether they were
extremely primitive in the form of moles
themselves or whether they were human
beings it would basically speed up their
evolution to the next stage now the next
group after that was of course Atlantis
and Atlantis as we know were at least
those of you guys who were relatively
familiar with Marvel Comics now is
that's where name of the Submariner
comes from well of course because
Atlantis had been around for thousands
and thousands of years if not you know
millions of years you had old Atlantis
which was ruled by a group of those
individuals who held on to
old beliefs and the the idea was that
they were going to overthrow the new
Atlantean Empire led by name with a
submariner
and they were going to basically take
the surface back and so this led to the
whole involvement of Susan storm being a
sort of go-between for name with a
submariner to deal with the old
Atlanteans and for the old Atlanteans to
be kept in check to keep from seeing
their plans of taking over the world
coming to fruition now that said the the
fourth group came in the form of a
nihilist his forces that existed in the
negative zone and all they wanted to do
was basically open a portal to earth and
to conquer earth along with the rest of
reality they were pretty straightforward
and the easiest to understand so again
it sort of rehash this our first group
was the universal Inhumans our second
group were the occupants of the forever
city our third group was old Atlantis
and our fourth group was our I guess is
a nihilist and his forces now what we're
gonna see is that with this coming to
fruition because of the fact that
Valyria Richards had accessed the portal
that had been created by Reed whereby he
encountered the multiversal versions of
himself in the form of the council of
reeds when she did this what we find out
is that she basically escaped alongside
these other reeds when the mad
Celestials were still laying waste to
the council chamber and so we have about
four or five different verses of Reed
from this council who are within the
main earth-616 universe of Marvel Comics
and so what we do here is we pick up
with dr. doom we pick up with the fact
that he again is basically going to help
Reed destroy him or at least destroy
these other Reed Richards and so once we
begin to get into this we basically see
that invitations are being sent out to
various people of course to the High
Evolutionary to Diablo to the mad
thinker to the wizard and one thing I'd
like you to take note of here is that
these invitations are being sent out to
some of the most formidable or at least
some of the most some of the oldest
villains of the Fantastic Four and
there's a reason for this because of the
fact that this council has effectively
been assembled for the purpose of
defeating Reed Richards who better to
reach out to than the people who have
fought him for so long and so the idea
is to bring all their minds together for
the purpose of using their experience to
destroy Reed but what happens is that
once this Council will convene
The Watcher appears now for those of you
guys who don't know before The Watcher
was killed in the original sin leading
up to secret Wars
whenever The Watcher showed up at an
event it meant that [ __ ] was gonna pop
off it's basically the best way to put
it
things were gonna go crazy and it was he
always appeared during a time when
something would take place that would
affect the universe and this is Reed's
reaction because of the fact of the
Watchers here because valaria was the
one who said about the idea of having
all these villains come together of
bringing dr. doom on for the purpose of
defeating Reed and because the fact that
Valyria had gone through the portal Reed
Richards reaction is what is she done
she basically set in motion a series of
events that will reshape the entire
landscape of the Marvel Universe and so
what we do here is we actually pick up
several months after this council
originally convenes and we join with the
different versions of Reed Richards from
the Council of Reed's as they're going
around to these different forced cities
then initially we pick up with the old
Atlanteans and what we find is that one
of these Reed's is creating subversion
within the old Atlanteans themselves
because the Atlanteans were composed of
different tribes what he does is he's
basically says one tribe was going to
betray the other and he's effectively
just planting the seeds of civil war
planted the seeds of dissent among these
old Atlanteans not from here we jump to
the forever city and what happens is we
pick up with this version of Reed who
basically says that the entire premise
here is to effectively use this
ascension engine that was created by the
High Evolutionary as an engine of sorts
to basically power a device that would
that they're gonna create now we'll find
out what this device is here in a little
bit at this point we basically find out
that this Reed is meeting with the we're
meeting with Mole Man the person who
originally discovered this and the
reason why this is important is because
there's a lot of manipulation and a lot
of subterfuge going on here what mole
man says is that the problem he faces is
various Malloy's that is to say those
weird-looking organisms that are
subservient to him they have been
leaving him and they've been going to
the forever city and they've been having
their evolution jump-started then the
more this happens the more mole the
marmalades leave and so the bargain is
being struck here is that if Mole Man
will basically work with this
read then they will effectively he'll
he'll effectively set it up so that his
Molloy's won't leave anymore they won't
be able to access the city and so what
we do at this point is we jump into the
realm of another one of the reads who's
talking to the universal and humans and
what happens this is actually a perfect
example I'd like you to keep this in the
back of your mind because this will be
important for the battle that happens
later on but what happens here is this
read initially becomes extremely
arrogant and what I mean by that is he
goes into the situation not thinking
about the consequences he wants to again
be manipulative he effectively wants to
pit the Inhumans in a war against the
other four cities that's really where
all this comes from but because of the
fact that he's going against a telepath
from the Centauri race who are well
known for their telepathic prowess his
mind is read more so than he expects and
they immediately detected subterfuge and
so what happens is they set about
basically imprisoning him interrogating
him studying his mind and finding out
exactly what the full scope of their
plan is and so finally the last read
that we pick up with before we begin to
wrap back around two events that are
currently transpiring is this read this
meeting with the cult of Annihilus now
again the cult of Annihilus was a group
that existed within the main earth-616
universe but they worshiped the concept
of Annihilus and so once this version of
read begins speaking with Annihilus
himself the question is if they help
Annihilus what does he want in return
for his help and so Annihilus says and
the only way he'll help this read is if
reid opens the portal to the negative
zone and then leaves it open allowing
Annihilus forces to come pouring in now
again I know we're kind of grabbing
things here I know it may seem a little
off in terms of word as that we're
coming from and why these things are
being done but what hickman does is he
starts wrapping these different things
up together then what we're told is that
these reads are basically building
something called Saul's anvil and Saul's
anvil is a very important concept in
Hickman's Fantastic Four and I want you
to keep this in the back of your head
because this will become very important
especially when we start dealing with
the situation of Galactus but what we
learn is that in order for Saul's anvil
to work the way it's supposed to it
requires a lot of different things but
the reason why
old Atlantis was getting special
attention was because these reeds
required a hyper thermal vent basically
meaning it was a way for them to access
water stores or to use superheated water
in order to allow the energy that would
be put off by Seoul's anvil to vent out
of the planet instead of simply just
blowing that energy down into the planet
and then cracking it into the other part
of this was that they required the
ascension engine to basically power it
they require the annihilation forces to
keep the forces of Reed Richards and the
various superheroes of Earth at bay to
keep these individuals from conflicting
with their plans and they required the
universal and humans to be another
component for this Sol's anvil that
would actually allow them to go forward
into the universe beginning to sort of
conquer it and for them to serve their
purpose and so what we do here is we
jump back to the Council of doom we jump
back to this gathering of these various
villains of Reed Richards past and their
plans to defeat the remainders of a
Council of reeds and what's really
interesting about this is it basically
throws into sharp relief the problem
that these villains have of course they
don't really fight amongst each other
we'll see some of that happen later on
but the bigger issue here is they're not
looking at the situation for how it is
they're looking at the situation for how
they want it to be what reed says here
is that valaria opening that chamber set
up a series of events that simply just
can't be undone there's no way to get
past this anymore and the other half of
this is that the villains begin looking
at it so they're facing off against Reed
Richards himself but what Reed says is
that these members of the council are
not like him they gave up their family
they gave up their friends they gave up
virtually anything that could be used
against them their singular purpose
their one goal is to basically take over
the universe and then find a way back
home and continue their role of
controlling the multiverse in and of
itself and so what happens is Nathaniel
Richards basically steps up and says
this is their weakness this is the
problem that everybody's not looking at
they're looking at it like they're
facing Reid but they're not they're
facing totally different individuals who
have common goals they have common
themes but the weakness that they have
is their desperation their weakness is
the fact that they want to get back home
and so the easiest way to defeat them is
to prevent that from happening
and so while Reed Richards and the
various individuals don't necessarily
grasp what it is that Nathaniel saying
Nathaniel says what is it Reed would do
if Reed were in a situation that he
didn't think he'd get out of if Reed
were in a situation where he seemed
overwhelmed by the events that were
transpiring and he wanted a way to sort
of let his mind wonder in order to keep
himself preoccupied but also focus on
the variables as well as the facts what
would he do and Reed says they're
building a machine which of course we
know to be Saul's anvil and so what
happens here is Valerius says yes she
knows about it yes she knows about that
device but the first step in order for
them to acquire this is to basically get
to old atlantis and so what happens is
the the Fantastic Four I guess the
future foundation at this point begin to
head out to old Atlantis but while this
is happening Susan storm has also been
summoned to old Atlantis because of the
fact that the subterfuge that that
version of Reed had been working on the
one that had been planting the seeds of
civil war has basically come to fruition
and the old Atlanteans are fighting
amongst themselves and so what happens
is that while susan is there and while
Susan spider-man and a couple other
members of the Future Foundation help to
basically fight off these forces in the
end they appear to be overwhelmed in
addition to this they're joined by the
forces of the Mole Man and so it's
basically a situation where everybody is
against the Fantastic Four but more so
than that because Reed isn't there to
necessarily explain everything that's
going on as the conflict begins to
unfold the alternate reality version of
Reed Richards the one that was part of
the Council of reeds and was sowing the
seeds of civil war reveals himself and
to Susan's eyes this is her husband this
is the actual Reed Richards the so she's
very confused and she's absolutely
baffled as to what's going on and so
what happens is this evil version of
Reed plays on that he takes that idea
that Susan is momentarily distracted and
effectively attacks her and so while
she's temporarily incapacitated of
course she's not severely injured and
she's not dead
spider-man tends to her and Alex one of
the members of the Future Foundation
does what he can to basically take out
these forces or the very least to keep
them at bay and to keep them from
destroying the city of old Atlanta
this and so while he's not necessarily
successful owing to the fact that that
version of Reid is able to take old
Atlantis away as they want to whisk it
away and open up this thermal vent for
access what we do is we pick up with
Reed Richards and one of the most
dangerous situations that any man could
be in dealing with an angry wife and so
what happens here is as he's talking to
Susan storm her question is when
Spiderman was telling read about
everything that was going on with that
battle Reid was not really shocked when
he said an alternate reality version of
himself had taken an old Atlantis away
the question she has is why what was he
not shocked why was he expecting to hear
something like that and so he
effectively sits down and tells her
everything that's going on he tells her
that he opened a portal to basically
solve the problem of everything that he
walked through that portal that he
encountered alternate reality versions
of himself from all across the
multiverse that they had all abandoned
their families they had left their wives
and children they had left their friends
behind and that the Celestials from an
alternate reality had effectively laid
waste of that council and that Reid was
not willing to to take those same steps
and effectively left he disbanded her
seemed to abandon the council in favor
of keeping his family and so what we do
here is we jump to the forever city of
the High Evolutionary and again we see
more of these reeds spending time with
one another and this is where the
bargain begins to come into play if
these individuals who are part of the
forever city if they will close their
doors off to the Mole Man and to the to
the moloids who would otherwise seek to
enter the city
then these Reed Richards will work on a
way to ensure the long-term survival of
these members of the forever city now
the reason why is because with their
evolution being jump-started the way
that it is they're still not able to
procreate the way they need to because
that facet of them just isn't available
it's not worked into their genes that's
the reason one of the reasons why
evolution works the way it does is to
ensure things begin moving in a forward
direction naturally but because they
were artificially sped up their bodies
don't function right and so because of
that if these Reed's are able to
effectively cure them then it won't be a
problem anymore in order for them to
achieve access to this improvement on
their physiology they also have to
basically work on the
and fix it so that it'll go back to its
previous standard that way the reads can
enhance it to their to their desires in
order to make it work the way they
wanted to and so what happens here is
that as they're as they're working on
this Saul's anvil heirs are working on
this machine where ultimately I guess
met with the return of Earth's in humans
and the reason why this matters is
because with Earth's and humans having
been gone during an event called the war
of Kings which dealt with Vulcan the
third summers brother who's an
omega-level mutant seizing control of
the Shiar Empire in Black Bolt who led
the Kree Empire waging war against one
another it opened the stage it opened
the the platform for the universal in
humans to try to acquire earth in the
first place and so with the Inhumans
back with the Inhumans looking at both
these Universal in humans as usurpers as
well as the actions of these various
Reed's going in direct conflict with
what it is that they wanted to achieve
we eventually see that these Inhumans
begin to just wage war they effectively
just begin crushing every single person
who would otherwise I see to oppose them
or usurp the position now this is
actually really cool and the reason why
this is interesting is because this is
in direct opposition to the kind of
inhuman stories that we're getting right
now with with Marvel Comics the Inhumans
stories that we're getting at the moment
really aren't that great but this run of
the Inhumans give them a dynamic aspect
they give them range they make them
interesting they make them intriguing
because they have motivation they have
desire as opposed just kind of being
people who were there but the fact
remains that we basically joined the the
versions of Reed temporarily as the
Inhumans start to lay waste to the city
as they just begin killing off every
single occupant every single person
that's there now what we do here is we
actually take a break for a second and
we jump back to the Baxter building I
know it really feels like we're jumping
around a lot I know it feels like we're
bouncing around a lot but there's going
to be motivation behind this and there's
going to be a reason because this is
going to clear up a lot of stuff and
it'll let us move forward without having
to worry about any of these lingering
things but picking up with Susan storm
we see her meeting with Nathaniel
Richards and this is interesting here
it's not a super important thing but
it's interesting here and the reason why
is because it tells us that Susan storm
doesn't really trust Nathaniel
yes he is playing a smart yes he's
giving them information from the future
but in her mind the futures not written
in stone the futures not guaranteed but
for Nathaniel he knows their futures
guaranteed and so in terms of their
ideologies it's the perfect example of
an unstoppable force meeting an
immovable object but the other half of
this though is we have to remember that
Susan storm is operating on information
given to her by the future version of
her daughter valaria where Valerius said
that dark times are coming that hard
times are coming and that no matter what
happens Susan is going to have to stay
strong and so to this moment I guess at
the very least it seems as though this
is what Susan is doing she's staying
strong in the face of the fact it would
be so much easier to just give in to the
thing I'll just say yes you're right
okay fine we'll do whatever you tell us
to as opposed to trying to avoid him
we're trying to block his every turn and
so what we do here is we transition away
from the Baxter building and we pick up
with Reed Richards and the Council of
doom
after the conflict in the forever city
and what happens is that as they're
going through of course they have a
force field to protect themselves from
the radiation of the ascension engine
which has been given to them by dr. doom
again if this force field wasn't there
their evolution would just a jumpstart
and who knows how they would turn out
but as they begin to go through and is
it begin to investigate what they also
do is they have a plan and their plan is
to effectively take out each individual
version of Reed that's that's present
here and to remove them from the
situation to basically conquer their
plan and so as they're going through and
as they're pulling these things off one
of the coolest moments in in dr. doom
actually happens here while Reed
Richards is fighting alongside the
Council of doom he's actually taken away
by Medusa and by lockjaw who of course
is in a human that teleports people away
but during this during this conflict dr.
doom encounters one of the versions of
Reed and Reed initially says you have no
business being here you have no business
you know and conflicting with our plans
and dr. doom just slaps them across the
face and says do not speak again unless
us to answer my questions this is not a
huge deal it's not major to the story
it's just great to see dr. doom doing
this kind of stuff
but while doom isn't here
gaining this alternate reality version
of read he's actually attacked from
behind by the madfinger and diablo now
the reason why Hickman gives us this is
because while this will go towards you
know the I guess the wrapping up so to
speak or the tying up of loose ends with
regards to the Council of doom it's also
a great homage to the history of the
Fantastic Four that when it comes down
to it the mad faker in Diablo are very
basic they're BCD level villains there
there are nowhere near dr. doom in terms
of popularity or even in terms of
capabilities and this is proven by the
fact that dr. doom after being attacked
and turns around and he basically says
you would try to kill me with fire of
all things they try to kill him with
fire and he turns around and he says
world be damned
doom indoors and for those of guys who
don't really read comics that much of
this is your first experience with
Doctor Doom and Marvel Comics this is
why we as Kalibak fans loved dr. doom
because he's got the best lines ever
he's so arrogant but he's so cool at the
same time and so what happens is that
because the mad thinker is a villain
that prides himself on analyzing the
entirety of a situation because he's he
prides himself on the idea that no one
else seems to understand or seems to
analyze the same variables he does and
he believes himself to have always come
out on top because of that he tries to
pull this with doom he basically tries
to barter the life of Diablo he says
that if doom you know accounts for the
variables that no one expects if he is a
a caring and a giving individual if he's
a compassionate person then that would
change the situation nobody would see
that coming and doom should do that and
doom says no and he basically just seems
to kill Diablo here and so what happens
is that as we jump back to Attilan as we
jump back to the Inhumans we see of
course the arrival of spider-man of of
Nathaniel Richards and of the main
earth-616 Reed Richards and this is
really interesting here this is really
cool because this is classic game humans
here but for those of you guys who
weren't really familiar with with the
previous Inhumans the way they existed
before Secret Wars you had Black Bolt
who was the leader who couldn't speak
because his voice would kill anybody
that he spoke to but you also had medusa
who spoke for him just by reading his
body language and and so on and so forth
but with the character of medusa and
with with black ball what we learned
is that their actions of laying waste to
everyone that seems to seems to be
usurpers it's basically just inhuman
justice this is just the way it is the
Inhumans themselves don't really go
about you know traditional justice the
way that we would do it in terms of
human society we don't put people on or
they don't put people on trial they
don't you know have them you know
determined determined to be guilty or
innocent by a jury of their peers they
just kill stuff they just wipe things
out it's just how they do it and it's
really not you know something to read
too deep into it's just the way they do
things but the fact remains that with
the Inhumans going through an attacking
virtually everybody that's the wizard
and his advanced idea mechanics henchmen
seem to vacate they seem to basically
bail out and so what we do here is we
pick up with a high evolutionary who
gets to the ascension engine and he says
that this has basically been modified
it's been adjusted yes it's been
adjusted beyond his expectations but it
doesn't serve the purpose that it was
originally designed to serve anymore
it's basically been transformed into a
power source and so while there are a
few things that happen here and there
while Reed Richards is basically made to
look on and watch is the events unfold
in the forever city we of course see the
insane brother of Black Bolt Maximus the
mad going through and attacking people
and this is just kind of some fun stuff
this is really just a little bit of a
filler things that are given in here but
overall the arc here is that the various
versions of Reed almost all of them are
defeated they're basically defeated and
taken prisoner by the Inhumans and the
reason why I say almost all is because
while Doom is initially invited to the
inhuman sea he of course turns it down
and the reason he turns it down is
because he spots one of the reeds who
has not been captured yet who's
basically watching the events unfold now
something I'd like you to take note of
is for those of you guys who have not
been watching or not seeing my hickman
video so far yes this version of reed
has an Infinity Gauntlet but because
he's in a universe that's not his own
the Infinity Gauntlet doesn't work here
why he continues to wield the Infinity
Gauntlet I'm not really sure it seems
just to just be a part of his character
in the same way that Professor X has a
wheelchair that dr. doom has a metal
suit it's just part of who he is but it
also helps us to distinguish between
this version of Reed
the council of reeds and our main
earth-616 reed but what is it up
happening is that while doom goes
against this version of reed that
version of reed responds by saying that
he's fought doom countless times you
know he's fought an infinite number of
dooms on an infinite number of worlds he
knows every move the doom is going to
make before he even makes it and this is
interesting because with dr. doom as a
villain he prides himself on his
intelligence but what this version of
Reed is saying is that doom is
predictable that he's really not as
smart as he believes he is that have
given enough time he himself is nothing
if not a series of patterns he's nothing
if not a guy that just does the same
thing over and over again which is
actually Hickman telling us this is a
reason why I do get to beat all time
because he keeps using the same schemes
all the time but the fact remains that
this reed uses one of those collars that
was used to turn all the versions of dr.
doom and a vegetable z' and he puts it
around dooms neck but what we also
learned is that the collar does not
automatically turn a person into a
vegetable and instead he turns the
collar down so that doom is effectively
just made his slave under the threat
that if doom does not do what he's told
that the collar is going to be turned
out to max power and so again what we do
is we go back to the to the city of
Attilan and we pick up with Reed and we
pick up with Nathaniel and spider-man as
this entire conflict it's sort of
wrapped up and so for those of you guys
who may have gotten a little confused or
a little lost in the conversation so far
the overall gist here is that the reads
of the the council were basically
creating Saul's anvil a way to open a
dimensional rift in order to access
their own world and in order to access
the council but the only way they could
do that was to use aspects of the four
cities and so while they attempted to do
what they could by implanting subterfuge
in the end they were defeated when the
Inhumans showed up and just clean house
and so with this event coming to an end
or at least with this aspect of the
story coming to an end what we find is
that Reed Nathaniel and spider-man are
presented with Eldrick now for those of
you guys who don't know not all Inhumans
who were exposed to the Terrigen mists
become powerful people not all of them
become like black bold or Medusa some of
them become the dog lockjaw
others become Eldrick which is a door
that takes you wherever you need to be
it doesn't mean that it'll take you
where you want to go it'll take you
where you
need to go and so it basically reads you
on a very subconscious level but there's
also some some veiled allusions here
that maybe the door of aldrick also
understands you know the future or it
understands how things will turn out and
it basically takes you where you need to
go in accordance to how the universe is
supposed to unfold and what future
events are gonna be taking place again
Hickman doesn't give us a whole lot here
on this we're kind of left to our own
devices to interpret exactly how the
door functions with regards to the need
of the person that travels through it
but the fact remains that once Reid and
Nathaniel and spider-man go through this
door we pick up with Reed Richards and
his arrival back at the Baxter building
now this is extremely important to the
future of events that happen especially
during the Thanos conversation with Reed
Richards which will actually probably be
coming here in the next you know two or
three videos or so and what happens is
once he gets back to the Baxter building
he's there with Susan and he tells her
everything that's going on the entire
conflict with the Inhumans how they went
through Eldrick and Eldrick took them
where they needed to be and he says it
apparently he just needed to be here he
just needed to be with his wife and this
is a big deal because what Susan says is
that by reiterating what valaria told
her that dark days are coming and that
even if alaria had not visited Susan
storm and even if alaria had not told
Susan storm that that dark days were
coming Susan would know it's simply just
by intuition and that's a legitimate
claim yeah I wouldn't go as far as to
say Susan storm has precognition or
anything like that but I will say that
she seems to have always been accurate
in terms of her ability to perceive that
things aren't the way they're supposed
to be and so what she tells Reed and
again this is extremely important that
Reed seems to have gotten lost in his
attempt to solve the problem of
everything with the realization that the
Council of Reed members or at least as
Sullivan had made it into his universe
the attempt to stop him that maybe he's
fighting a losing battle that maybe the
these events are just supposed to unfold
and all Reed can do is watch them on
full to the fruition and then try to
stop some final event that occurs at
some point in the future now again this
is something that I really want you to
keep in the back of your head because we
will reference this especially when we
see the return of the adult Franklin
Richards but because of the
that the actions of these various reads
still leave on the chest table the
possible invasion of Annihilus it brings
to light the fact that the earth itself
is still in extreme danger and so what
happens is that while Ben Grimm had
departed the Fantastic Four for a time
to basically kind of focus things and in
light of Johnny Storm dying what he does
as he returns at the behest of
spider-man but he brings The Avengers
with him and so what we do here is we
pick up in the Baxter building itself
and we basically joined Reed Richards
and all Reed really does is effectively
explain everything that's going on he
tells them everything that's happening
the fact that dr. doom appears to have
been taken prisoner by one of the reads
he tells them about the council he tells
them about all these events unfolding
and that while we did what he could
while he did what he thought was the
right thing to do this is ultimately all
just backfired and so he's effectively
assembled the Avengers or at least a
huge number of the Avengers in order to
combat this threat and we see the creme
de la creme of Marvel Comics here some
of the most powerful and popular
Avengers we of course see Iron Man we
see Luke Cage iron fist we have Carol
Danvers we have Wolverine we have Red
Hulk
we have Doctor Strange we have some
pretty powerful folks here and you know
with regards to their own right we also
see a few x-men and this really presents
a circumstance whereby things could
really begin to go crazy things could
really begin to pop off and the reason
why I say that is because during the
event of war of kings the supreme
intelligence had been destroyed and if
you guys recall my discussion on the
Inhumans we had talked about how the
supreme intelligence had the entire
inhuman project of decommissioned
because of the fact that the Inhumans
would at some point in the future rise
up against the Kree Empire and destroy
it and so what happens is with the with
these versions of Reed being taken
prisoner by the Inhumans themselves
they're effectively handed over to Ronon
the accuser who is really like the
Stewart of the Kree Empire while Black
Bolt is not there and so these two
Reed's are handed over to Ron in the
accused
and they are brought together their
minds are effectively melded together
and they are transformed to
transmogrified into the supreme
intelligence and so because the supreme
intelligence has basically returned and
encompasses all the knowledge of all the
Kree rulers that have ever existed he
also now has the knowledge of these
these two Reed Richards to go along with
it meaning this supreme intelligence is
now knowledgeable on a multiversal scale
not just a universal scale but the fact
remains that because of the fact that
the supreme intelligence had been dead
for so long that in the end the goal is
to still destroy the Inhumans and so
what happens is the supreme intelligence
since fourth the Armada of the Kree race
sends them all towards the planet Earth
and this comes on the heels of the
Avengers going forward with the
intention of facing off against the
forces of the annihilation wave assuming
they advance facing off against the the
I guess remainders of the rete the
various members of the Council of reeds
who are still running around the planet
Earth and so in response to the fact
that the Kree could very well destroy
the entirety of the human population
Reed Richards basically sends out an SOS
and in response to this SOS is the
arrival of Galactus with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and the reason why is because those of
you guys who read Hitman's Fantastic
Four you guys know that in the next
video which will be out tomorrow things
get crazy anyway guys we're gonna wrap
this up I hope you guys enjoyed it let
me know what you guys think about
Hickman's Fantastic Four so far because
if you guys have had a few jaw-dropping
moments so far it ain't nothing compared
to what comes out in the next video I
know you guys hate cliffhangers I'm
sorry I got to do it to you but uh yeah
I'll catch you guys later
face
[Music]